Well, you guys know we love Airbnb. I also just did a ladies' birthday trip. It was my friend's 50th birthday. All of us gals drove up the coast. It was so fun. We had the kitchen to hang out in, but then we all had our own space because, you know, we love each other. But I mean, I kind of want my own space at night. You know what I'm saying. We love the privacy. They're always in such great locations where you can really get to know the town you're in. And there's some real hidden gyms out there. These little pockets and neighbors, that you might not see if you stayed at a hotel. Listen, I could go on and on about Airbnb because I love it. It's a great way to travel with friends and family. And you know, your home might be perfect for Airbnb. If you frequently travel or have extra space, maybe you go out of town at the same time every year for a family trip. Your home could earn you money while you're away. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.ca. Hello, everybody. Hi there. So you've opened your podcast app and here in your office ladies' feed, you have found how we made your mother? What is going on here? Have we been hacked by another rewatch podcast?
哦，你们知道我们很喜欢 Airbnb。我最近还去了一趟女士生日之旅。那是为我朋友庆祝五十岁生日。我们这帮姐妹开着车沿着海岸线一路北上。太有趣了。我们一起在厨房里聊天，但每个人都有自己的私人空间，因为，你知道的，我们感情很好。不过说实话，到了晚上我还是想要点自己的空间，你懂我的意思吧。我们都很注重隐私。他们的房源位置总是那么好，能让你真正融入你所在的城镇。那里还有很多真正的隐秘好去处。那些小角落和邻居，如果你住酒店可能根本看不到。听着，关于 Airbnb 我可以滔滔不绝地说个不停，因为我太爱它了。这是和亲朋好友一起旅行的绝佳方式。而且你知道的，你的家可能非常适合放在 Airbnb 上出租。如果你经常旅行或有闲置空间，或者也许你们每年都在同一时间离开外地进行家庭旅行。当你不在家时，你的房子可以为你赚钱。你的房子可能比你想象的更有价值。快去 Airbnb.ca 了解具体价值。大家好。你们好。所以，当你打开播客应用，在“办公室女士”（Office Ladies）的动态里，你发现了《我们是怎么抚养你妈的》（How We Made Your Mother）？这到底是怎么回事？我们是被另一个重温类播客黑了嘛？
Angela, are the machines finally rising up against us? No, not yet anyway. Sit tight, survivalist lady. All is right in the world. for now, and we have some big news. If you checked out our episode from October 15th, you can hear the whole story. But in short, you probably know that we have launched the Office Ladies Network, and I'm sure you already have been listening to Lazy Genius. Thank you very much, with the amazing Kendra Adachi. Yes, well, we have now added our first rewatch podcast to the network, and it is
安吉拉，机器们终于开始反抗我们了吗？不，至少现在还没有。稍安勿躁，求生达人。一切都好。目前一切正常，而且我们有个重大消息。如果你查看了我们10月15日的单集，你就能听到整个故事。简而言之，你可能知道我们推出了“办公室女士”播客网（Office Ladies Network），而且我敢肯定你已经听过《懒人天才》（Lazy Genius）了。非常感谢，由神奇的肯德拉·安达奇（Kendra Adachi）主持。没错，我们现在在这个网络中加入了我们的第一个重温类播客，那就是
how we made your mother, looking back at nine seasons of how I met your mother. The podcast is hosted by Josh Radner, who of course played TED on the show, along with Craig Thomas, who is one of the co-creators of How I Met Your Mother. I love it when Josh says, I am the I and how I met your mother. I play The Eye. Well, Josh and Craig do a deep dive not only into the characters and plots of each episode, but they are also taking a close look at the issues the show confronted, love and loss, commitment, rejection, friendship, careers, everything. That is honestly my favorite part of this podcast is when they take a storyline about one of these topics and then they discuss it. They discuss that theme and why they made the choices
《我们是怎么抚养你妈的》，回顾《老爸老妈浪漫史》（How I Met Your Mother）的九季内容。该播客由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）主持，他在剧中饰演泰德（TED），还有克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas），他是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的联合创作者之一。我特别喜欢乔什说：“我就是《老爸老妈浪漫史》里的那个‘我’。我扮演的就是‘我’。”乔什和克雷格不仅深入探讨了每集的情节和角色，他们还密切关注了该剧所面对的种种议题：爱情与失落、承诺、拒绝、友情、事业，应有尽有。说实话，我最喜欢这个播客的部分，就是当他们挑选出关于这些主题的某条故事线，然后进行讨论。他们会探讨这个主题，以及他们为什么要做出那些决定
they made to have the characters do the things they did. Oh, it's amazing. But they also talk about what it felt like to be in an early to mid-2000s long-running network sitcom, which is a topic, of course, very close to our office ladies' hearts. And also close to our office ladies' hearts is the community that they have built for their podcast. Everyone, it is going to feel familiar to you. The warmth, the kindness, the encouragement that their community has is absolutely office ladies' community. It so is. And I love hearing from their fans, you really hear them in each episode. So you guys, they have just finished the first season of the podcast covering the first season of the show. Yes. And now we are bringing you the very first episode of their second
让角色做出那些行为。哦，太棒了。但他们也会聊聊置身于2000年代初中期那种长期播出的电视网情景喜剧中的感受，这个话题当然也深深触动了我们“办公室女士”的心。同样触动我们“办公室女士”之心的，还有他们为自己的播客建立的粉丝社群。各位，你们会觉得倍感熟悉。他们的社群所拥有的温暖、善良和鼓励，完全就是“办公室女士”的社群风格。确实如此。而且我特别喜欢听他们粉丝的声音，你在每一集里都能真切地听到他们的心声。所以大家伙儿，他们刚刚结束了该播客的第一季，内容涵盖了该剧的第一季。是的。现在我们要带给大家的是他们第二季的
season. We love it. We think you'll love it. If you want to binge season one, you can go subscribe to How We Made Your Mother. But you can also start right here. Honestly, this episode is terrific. And you can listen wherever you get your podcast, or you can head to their website, How We Made Your Mother.com. And of course, you can find them on socials at How We Made Your Mother. And here we go. We are proud to present the newest member of the Office Ladies Network, How We Made Your Mother with Josh Radner and Craig Thomas. Hello, this is Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey from the Office Ladies podcast in Los Angeles.
第一集。我们很喜欢。相信你们也会喜欢。如果你想一口气刷完第一季，可以去订阅《我们是怎么抚养你妈的》。但你也可以从这里直接开始。说实话，这一集棒极了。你可以在任何收听播客的地方听到它，或者也可以访问他们的网站：How We Made Your Mother.com。当然，你也可以在社交媒体上通过 How We Made Your Mother 找到他们。接下来，我们隆重推出“办公室女士”播客网的最新成员——由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持的《我们是怎么抚养你妈的》。大家好，我是来自洛杉矶“办公室女士”播客的珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。
And something we love about how we made your mother is the amazing community of this show. The fans and people that write in, we think you guys are awesome. And I love when Josh and Craig get philosophical. I mean, I love all the behind-the-scenes stories, but my favorite is when Josh suddenly starts quoting Einstein or some ancient philosopher, and then he and Craig basically break down the meaning of love, or the power of friendship, or forgiveness, or you name it. But I often find myself feeling a little lighter, a little more hopeful after listening. And that's a pretty special. special thing to be able to do. And that's why we're thrilled to be adding the show to our
我们喜欢《我们是怎么抚养你妈的》的一点，就是这个节目拥有令人惊叹的社群。那些粉丝和写信来的人，我们觉得你们太棒了。而且我特别喜欢乔什和克雷格变得富有哲理的时候。我的意思是，我喜欢所有幕后故事，但我最喜欢的还是乔什突然开始引用爱因斯坦或某个古代哲学家的名言，然后他和克雷格基本上开始剖析爱的真谛、友谊的力量、宽容，或是随便什么主题。但我经常发现听完之后，自己会觉得轻松一点，对生活多了一点希望。能做到这一点可真是一件了不起的事情。这也是为什么我们很高兴能将这个节目加入到我们的
Office Ladies Network. Welcome, guys! Oh, and you better have us as guests real soon. Uh-huh. Get on it. I'm alone. What a pity. I won't be soon in New York City when I see you. Please permit me to tell you everything in New York. City. Well, here we are. Welcome to the first episode of Season 2 of How We Made Your Mother. I am Josh Radner. I played Ted Mosby on the TV show called How I Met Your Mother, which ran on CBS from 2005 to 2014. I am here with the co-creator of that show, Craig Thomas. Hello, Craig. It's great to see you. Hello, Josh. Very excited to be back here with you and the fans and our new
“办公室女士”播客网中。欢迎你们，伙计们！哦，你们最好快点邀请我们去当嘉宾。嗯哼。抓紧安排。我孤身一人。真可惜。当我见到你时，我不会很快去纽约市的。请允许我在纽约市告诉你一切。好了，我们到了。欢迎收看《我们是怎么抚养你妈的》第二季第一集。我是乔什·拉德纳。我在2005年至2014年在哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）播出的电视剧《老爸老妈浪漫史》中饰演泰德·莫斯伯格（Ted Mosby）。和我在一起的是该剧的联合创作者克雷格·托马斯。你好，克雷格。很高兴见到你。你好，乔什。非常高兴能在这里与你、粉丝们以及我们在“办公室女士”播客网的新
wonderful friends over at the Office Ladies Network. O-L-N, we sometimes call it, which is just to save us the energy of saying all those syllables. We don't have that kind of time. We're very busy people. Yeah, we got to get on with it. Tell this story. Yeah, tell this story. How did this happen?
好朋友们重聚。我们有时简称它为 O-L-N，这只是为了省得费劲去念那么多音节。我们可没有那种闲工夫。我们是大忙人。对，我们得抓紧。讲这个故事。对，讲这个故事。这是怎么发生的？
Yeah, we're delighted to be working with Jenna and Angela and their team. So the way this came about was, you know, we were a kind of lean-and-mean operation first season. me, Craig, Alec, Doug, Alex, just this very small team, and we were just doing this all on her own. And I called Jenna Fisher, my old pal from back in the days, because we were on big hit TV shows around the same time. So we got to know each other. And I was reaching out, one, to ask her advice as a trailblazer
对，我们很高兴能与珍娜、安吉拉以及她们的团队合作。事情是这样的，第一季的时候，我们其实是一个精简高效的团队。我和克雷格、亚历克、道格、亚历克斯，就这么一个小团队，一切都是我们自己包办的。我给珍娜·费舍尔打了电话，她是我当年的老朋友，因为我们差不多在同一时期出演过大热美剧。所以我们渐渐熟悉了起来。我联系她，一方面是想作为重温类播客领域的先行者向她讨教一些建议
in the rewatch podcast space. Oh, yes. If she had any advice for us, but also, more specifically, I wanted to see if she would come on our podcast to talk about the strangeness of being, you know, a decade or so of your life, being thought of as someone you're not, being, you know, the whirlwind of being on a hit show, like all these things. And before we even got into it, she said, are you guys working with a podcast company?
哦，是的。看她能不能给我们什么建议，但更具体地说，我是想看看她愿不愿意上我们的播客，来聊聊那种奇妙的感受——比如你生命中的十年左右，都被当成一个并不是你本人的人；比如身处热播剧中的那种旋风般的感受，诸如此类的事情。结果我们还没切入正题，她就问：“你们是在跟哪家播客公司合作吗？”
And I said, no. And she said, well, Angela and I have started our own podcast company called Office Ladies Network. And we would probably be delighted to have you on. She actually said we would be sight unheard, podcast unseen? Podcasts, like, how do you say that? Sounds unheard. Yeah. She just, and then her and Angela gave a couple episodes of spin and immediately called us and said,
我说没有。她说：“哦，我和安吉拉创办了自己的播客公司，叫‘办公室女士’播客网。我们非常乐意邀请你们加入。”她当时甚至说，我们还没听过你们的播客，甚至没看过……播客，怎么说来着？没听过声音吧。对。她直接……然后她和安吉拉把我们的单集拿去听了几集，立刻就打电话给我们说：
we love this. We'd love to pull you under the umbrella of the Office Ladies Network. We'd love to cross-pollinate in any ways that we could. And we're so delighted. We're so thrilled. Craig, what do you have to add? We're so honored, they would ask us. They're so good at it.
“我们太喜欢了。我们很乐意把你们纳入学‘办公室女士’播客网的羽翼之下。我们希望能以各种方式进行交叉推广。”我们感到无比高兴。我们太激动了。克雷格，你有什么要补充的吗？我们深感荣幸，他们竟然会邀请我们。他们太擅长这个了。
They're so good. Their show's so good. Jenna and Angela, they are trailblazers. They, you know, they kind of paved the way for, like, a comedy rewatch podcast like ourselves to come along, too. And so we're grateful that they kind of took us under their wing and were their partners now. Yeah, thank you guys. Thank you to Jenna. Thank you, Angela.
他们太厉害了。他们的节目太棒了。珍娜和安吉拉，她们是先行者。她们为像我们这样的喜剧重温类播客铺平了道路。所以我们很感激她们能把我们揽入羽翼之下，现在我们成为了合作伙伴。是的，谢谢你们。谢谢珍娜。谢谢安吉拉。
We're huge fans of the office. You will hear them on here and us on there. We really will kind of cross-pollinate. It's going to be great. We're very grateful. I mean, it's kind of cool that it's a, when we were growing up, like, crossover episodes, were, you know, like LeBern and Shirley would show up on happy days, right? It's true. I miss that. I miss that so much.
我们是《办公室》的超级粉丝。你们会在这里听到他们的声音，也能在那里听到我们的声音。我们确实会进行交叉推广。这一定会很棒。我们非常感激。我的意思是，这挺酷的，当我们长大时，跨界剧集这种事，你知道的，就像《拉弗恩与雪莉》（Laverne and Shirley）会出现在《欢乐时光》（Happy Days）里一样，对吧？确实如此。我很怀念那个。我太怀念了。
Tradition, and we didn't do that in our era. So we're doing it now with our rewatch podcasts. We're doing it now. I love it. I love retroactively. We're doing it in this other medium since TV's too hard now. It's too hard to make TV shows now, so now we'll just do it on a podcast. Yeah. So thank you, thank you to Jenna and Angela and their team over at Office Ladies Network. We're thrilled to be part of the And we are putting a pause on the YouTube segment. Craig and I'll just say this up front. Craig and I are aging aggressively.
这是一种传统，但在我们那个年代没有这样做。所以现在我们通过重温类播客来做这件事。我们现在正在这么做。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这种事后弥补的方式。既然现在拍电视剧太难了，我们就通过播客来做这件事。现在的电视剧太难拍了，所以现在我们就在播客上做。对。所以，谢谢珍娜、安吉拉以及她们在“办公室女士”播客网的团队。我们很高兴能成为……而且我们要暂停 YouTube 环节。克雷格和我要先说明这一点。克雷格和我的衰老速度非常激进。
Just very aggressively each day. I had a lot of work done over the summer. I don't know what you were talking about. It has not settled. It has not settled yet. It didn't tick. We cannot, in good conscience, we cannot show you Craig Thomas' face right now
每天都以非常激进的速度衰老。我在夏天做了很多医美。我不知道你在说什么。还没恢复好。还没消肿呢。没有对上号。我们问心无愧地说，现在我们不能向你展示克雷格·托马斯的脸
until his work settles. If you were watching the show over on YouTube, thank you. We loved having you go over there, and we're still going to have some video components to the show, but we're not going to be on YouTube every week. Yep, you'll see fun videos on our socials, but it won't be the full episode on YouTube. And you can monitor Craig's healing, which we're all pulling for. The bandages will come off about episode 11 or 12 that we're discussing. It's pretty hard to look at right now, I've got to be honest.
直到他的医美效果恢复自然。如果你一直在 YouTube 上看这个节目，谢谢你们。我们很喜欢你们去那边观看，而且我们以后仍会保留一些视频内容，但我们不会每周都在 YouTube 上更新了。是的，你们会在我们的社交媒体上看到有趣的视频，但不会是 YouTube 上的完整单集。你可以监督克雷格的恢复情况，我们都在为他加油。在我们讨论的大约第11集或第12集时，绷带就会拆下来了。老实说，现在确实很难直视。
There's like a drainage pipe going from each eye. Josh, I haven't had the work done yet. What is going on? It's coming up. It's next week. This is horrible. Why don't we get to it, Craig? Why don't we launch this season two?
每个眼睛下面都挂着一根引流管。乔什，我还没做医美呢。这到底是怎么回事？快要做了。就在下周。这太可怕了。我们为什么不开始呢，克雷格？我们为什么不开始第二季呢？
Turning now to our trusty producer, Alec, Alec, tell us the name of this episode and when it originally aired. Absolutely. And hi, guys. Welcome back. Hi, Alex. It's exciting. And I'm very excited also about this Office Ladies Network.
现在转向我们信赖的制作人亚历克。亚历克，告诉我们这一集的标题是什么，以及它最初是在什么时候播出的。没问题。大家好，欢迎回来。嗨，亚历克斯。真令人兴奋。我对这个“办公室女士”播客网也感到非常兴奋。
Jen and Angela have already been amazing to work with, thanks to them from me also. And Colin, who is part of their team as well. The episode is called Where Were We? It originally aired on September 18, 2006, written by Carter Bays and Craig Thomas. Where were we? It's a great question to ask. We love the meta title. We wrapped up season one, and I haven't seen you for years, and by years, I mean, like, six weeks, maybe.
珍娜和安吉拉一直以来都非常棒，合作起来很愉快，也要感谢她们，还有她们团队的科林（Colin）。这一集的标题是《我们身在何方？》（Where Were We?），它最初于2006年9月18日播出，由卡特·贝斯（Carter Bays）和克雷格·托马斯编剧。《我们身在何方？》这是一个很好的问题。我们很喜欢这种元叙事的标题。我们第一季结束了，我好几年没见你了，所谓的好几年，其实大概也就六周吧。
Six weeks. It's been the smallest summer hiatus I've ever had. It is a brief hiatus. It's not like the real, the real Hemium hiatus several months. I would not see you for a while. You would go off on crazy adventures. the writers would come back way before the actors. We'd work for like six, eight weeks before you got there.
六周。这是我有生以来最短的暑期休假。这确实是一个短暂的假期。不像真正的、真正维持数月的标准休假。我有一阵子见不到你。你会去进行疯狂的冒险。编剧们回到剧组的时间比演员早得多。在你们到达之前，我们要工作大概六、八周。
All the actors would come in looking tan and beautiful and be like, how was your guy summer? We'd be like, we're haggard and gray. We haven't seen the sun. Don't ask us how our summer was. But yeah, no, this was a quicker turnaround. So it's fun to jump right back in. I love the meta title of Where Were We?
所有的演员回来时都晒得黑黑的、漂漂亮亮的，然后问：“你们的夏天过得怎么样？”我们会说：“我们精疲力竭、满头白发。我们都没见着太阳。别问我们夏天过得怎么样。”不过说真的，这次制作周期更快一些。所以直接跳回来感觉很有趣。我超爱《我们身在何方？》这个元标题。
That was the feeling in trying to break this episode in the writer's room of like, how do we pick this up? And here's my first thought, Josh, when I started watching this. one, which I did last night and I loved it. I hadn't seen this in years and years and years and years. And the pressure coming in his episode was immense. We had been advised slash scolded to be less serialized by in between the two seasons, season one and season two, we did not agree with that advice and we didn't really take it. But we really wanted to come in and kill it to show that we could do this kind of serialized emotional comedy show on CBS and have it find an audience.
当我们在编剧室里构思这一集时，那种感觉就是：我们该如何承接上一季？乔什，我昨晚开始看这一集时，我的第一个想法是：第一，我昨晚看了，非常喜欢。我已经好多年好多年没看过这一集了。这一集面临的压力巨大无比。我们在第一季和第二季之间的休假期间，曾被建议或者说被数落要减少连续剧情节，我们并不同意这个建议，也没有真正采纳它。但我们真的很想一炮打响，证明我们能够在 CBS 制作这种具有连续性的情感喜剧，并找到它的受众。
but we weren't there yet, and so we really felt like we're singing for our supper. The thing, the first thought I had was, it's so funny that we had to speak to the summer passing to still stay in season for when the TV show was airing. You were just talking about crossover episodes in like 70s and 80s TV. Another seemingly now vestigial thing
但我们当时还没做到这一点，所以我们真的觉得自己是在为生计而战。我的第一个想法是：太搞笑了，为了配合电视剧播出的季节，我们不得不提及夏天的流逝。你刚才还在聊70年代和80年代电视剧中的跨界剧集。另一个现在看来已经过时的东西
is this idea that you have to be in the season where you're airing, right? On streaming, who cares? Who cares? Like, ooh, Andor, why is it winter in Andor? It's like, it's summer. while I'm watching it here in the real world. I'm turning this off. Yeah, but we, this is implausible now. But we, there was this kind of common understanding
就是这种必须与你播出的季节保持同步的想法，对吧？在流媒体时代，谁在乎呢？谁在乎啊？比如，哦，安多（Andor），为什么安多里是冬天？这就好比，我在现实世界里看的时候明明是夏天。我不看了。是的，但是我们……这在现在看来简直不可思议。但是我们……当时有一种共识
and we definitely didn't feel ready to buck of that conventional wisdom. You've got to come in basically in the season so you can catch up to your Thanksgiving episode and your Halloween episode and your Christmas episode, all that stuff. And you can be sort of in sync with where the viewer is watching it in time.
而我们绝对没有准备好去打破这种传统智慧。你基本上得在剧中对应的季节登场，这样你才能赶上你的感恩节特辑、万圣节特辑、圣诞节特辑，所有这些内容。而且你可以与观众在现实中观看的时间保持某种同步。
And that was what dictated the storytelling in this episode, showing the whole summer passing and kind of catching up to ourselves. Here we are again in September and New York City. I was laughing at the idea that shows just don't have to do that anymore. Well, let's just bring the listener up to speed. So where we last left are heroes, right? Yes.
正是这一点决定了这一集的故事走向，展示了整个夏天的流逝，并追赶上现实的进度。我们又回到了9月的纽约市。我当时还在笑，觉得现在的节目根本不需要这样做。好吧，让我们带听众们快速了解一下最新进展。所以我们上次离开我们的英雄们时，是怎样的呢？是的。
So Ted makes this bold move to Robin in the rain. He shows up. They have this grand, you know, romantic, cinematic kiss. he returns home to his Upper West Side apartment from Brooklyn, which is a longer trip than people realize. We've already established the geography is implausible that a woman in Brooklyn would hang out that much on the Upper West Side. But he gets back to the Upper West Side,
泰德在雨中对罗宾做出了这个大胆的举动。他出现了。他们有了一个盛大的、浪漫的、充满电影感的吻。他从布鲁克林回到他位于曼哈顿上西区的公寓，这比人们想象的要远得多。我们之前已经确定过这种地理设定很不合情理，一个住在布鲁克林的女人怎么会经常泡在上西区。但他回到了上西区
and he's delighted he can't wait to get home and tell Marshall and Lily. And Marshall is sitting out on the stoop holding the engagement ring. Lily is gone and devastated. So Ted has to pivot and sit down and sit with his best. friend as they get pelted with rain. One of my favorite moments in the whole series is that is you putting your arm around him on those steps. And that was the Block Party song, right?
他高高兴兴的，迫不及待地想回家告诉马歇尔和莉莉。而马歇尔正坐在台阶上，手里拿着订婚戒指。莉莉已经离开并且心碎欲绝。所以泰德不得不转变状态，坐下来，陪着他最好的朋友，任由雨水倾盆而下。整部剧里我最喜欢的时刻之一，就是你把胳膊搭在他肩膀上的那一幕，伴随着的是“街区派对”（Bloc Party）的歌，对吧？
Yep. This Modern Love by Block Party, one of my favorite needle drops, as they say, in the whole show. So that's where we end season one. I'm sure CBS was delighted by that happy waltz into the sunset ending. Tune in for more sadness in September. And I wrote you this little ditty.
没错。Block Party 的《这现代爱情》（This Modern Love），整部剧里我最喜欢的插曲之一，正如他们所说。这就是第一季的结尾。我敢确定 CBS 一定对这种开开心心走向日落的结局满意极了。请继续收看9月份更多的悲伤。我为你写了这首小曲儿
to sing to you in New York City. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. So then where were we? We popped back into this episode. And I think it's one thing that I told Jordana that was really funny as I was watching. I was like, so we're filming presumably an hour or two after they get inside, Robin has come over.
要在纽约市唱给你听。我们马上回来。现在，言归正传。那么，我们身在何方？我们切回了这一集。我觉得我跟乔丹娜说过一件很有趣的事，当时我正在看。我说，我们拍摄的时间大概是他们进屋后的一两小时，罗宾过来了。
Or maybe it's later that morning, right? No, yes, that's definitely. We're still wet from the rain, right? You can see that we've dried off a little. But there's four months between the end of that scene and I just remember, you know, the props or I think it was really wardrobe. They come through with spray bottles.
或者也许是那天晚些时候，对吧？不，是的，绝对是。我们身上的雨水还没干，对吧？你能看出我们已经稍微风干了一点。但那个场景的结尾和现在之间隔了四个月，我只记得，你知道的，道具，或者我觉得其实是服装部门。他们拿着喷雾瓶过来。
Yeah. And they're trying to get you wet, you know, and keep you kind of looking plausibly wet. And, but it's, it's such a funny time jump, especially because most TV and film is shot out of order. Yeah. So you have to really know the script well enough to keep that order in your head as you're going and know where your character is emotionally because, you know, you could shoot the most emotionally impactful scene in the first couple days. And then you're shooting the previous, you know, stuff. So it's wild.
对。他们试图让你身上弄湿，你知道的，让你看起来在情理之中还是湿漉漉的。但是，这是一个非常有趣的跨越时间的剪辑，尤其是因为大多数电视剧和电影都是打乱顺序拍摄的。对。所以你必须对剧本非常熟悉，才能在拍摄过程中把这种顺序记在心里，并知道你的角色在情感上处于什么位置，因为，你知道的，你可能会在头几天拍摄最具情感冲击力的场景。然后你再去拍前面那些……内容。所以这真的很疯狂。
But anyway, just give us a quick armchair summary, Craig, of what happens in season to episode one, where we're. were we? Yeah. I remember in the writer's room, like, feeling all this pressure until we realized two things. One, we're going to track the entire summer and show like Marshall's descent into madness through the summer and catch up to where we are. That was the idea one that unlocked it. And idea two was this credit card idea where Marshall gets a hold of in midway through the episode
不过话说回来，克雷格，请用局外人的视角简单总结一下，在第二季第一集《我们身在何方？》里到底发生了什么？是的。我记得在编剧室里，我们感受到了所有的压力，直到我们意识到两件事。第一，我们将追踪整个夏天，展示马歇尔在整个夏天陷入疯狂的过程，并追赶上我们现在的进度。这是解开这个难题的第一个构思。第二个构思是关于信用卡的，马歇尔在这一集中途拿到了莉莉的信用卡账单
of Lilly's credit card bill. It's sent to him and the idea of just these pieces of evidence of what she's been up to. And that's going to sort of steer the second half. of that episode. So basically this is showing the summer of these two roommates, one of whom is the happiest he's ever been, he got Robin, and one of whom is the absolute saddest that he's ever been. And that was just a compelling idea to us. You guys had so much fun. I could feel how much fun you had in playing with that idea that Ted is kind of euphoric. But it's a funny thing when your friend is down, you almost have to, like, put on your sad face with that.
账单寄给了他，而这些她最近动向的证据，将成为推动后半集剧情的关键。所以基本上，这展示了这两个室友的夏天，其中一个是他有生以来最快乐的，因为他得到了罗宾；而另一个则是他有生以来最痛苦的。这对我们来说是一个极具吸引力的构思。你们当时玩得太开心了。我能感受到你们在玩转这个构思时有多么开心，泰德处于一种极度兴奋的状态。但当你的朋友情绪低落时，这却是一件很有趣的事，你几乎不得不……摆出一副悲伤的面孔来。
Like, I mean, it's a kind thing to be empathetic and be like, buddy, I know. You know, and also it's hard to not be able to share your joy with your best friend of what's happening with you, you know. Oh, yes. I mean, the universe or whatever, the narrative storyteller who's writing this story, it's like, it never kind of, there's always this kind of, I've noticed, like, a, kind of friction between where you are and where your friends might be
我的意思是，富有同情心是一件善良的事，你会说：“老兄，我懂的。”你知道的，而且同时，很难在经历着美妙之事的自己和你最好的朋友之间分享你的喜悦，你知道的。哦，是的。我的意思是，宇宙或者别的什么，也就是编写这个故事的叙事者，它似乎……我注意到，你所处的位置和你的朋友们（甚至你的伴侣们）所处的位置之间，总是存在着某种摩擦。
or even your partners. And everyone's not always on the same page. And that's something you have to negotiate with friendship and with just living in the world. I loved what a good friend Ted was in that initial moment where Robin comes in and she's going to say something about her and Ted getting together
并不是每个人总是在同一频道上。这是你在处理友情以及在这个世界上生活时必须去协调的事情。我喜欢泰德在那个最初的时刻表现得是多么好的一个朋友，当时罗宾进来，正要说起她和泰德在一起的事
and he's like, no, there's only one thing that happened in the news last night. There's no other news stories here. And I loved Ted for that. And I think it really earned Ted's later moment. You see Ted really tending to Marshall's well-being the whole summer. And it felt very earned later in the episode when Ted does kind of say, enough, stop acting this way.
而泰德却说：“不，昨晚的新闻里只发生了一件事。这里没有其他新闻了。”我为此非常喜欢泰德。我觉得这为泰德后来的表现做了很好的铺垫。你看到泰德整个夏天都在悉心照料马歇尔的身心健康。后来当泰德终于说出“够了，别再这样演了”时，感觉非常顺理成章。
This isn't you. You'll never get her back or move on like this. And we'll get there, but I love that arc. That was Ted's arc in the episode to start off as the caretaker and then becomes the one who kind of really tries to shake him out of it in the end in a way that is almost a little too much, but it's great. And that idea, we've all been on, I think, both ends of that equation. We've been the miserable guy that's being scraped off the floor by our friends.
“这根本不是真正的你。你永远无法通过这样挽回她或继续生活。”我们稍后会聊到那里，但我很喜欢这条人物弧光。泰德在这一集里的人物弧光就是：一开始扮演照顾者的角色，然后在最后真正试图把马歇尔从这种状态中摇醒，虽然方式可能有点过头了，但真的很棒。这种构思，我想我们所有人都曾处于那个等式的两端。我们都曾当过那个被朋友从地上捞起来的痛苦家伙。
And we've been the super happy guy who's like, I can't be this happy around this person I love right now. I have to hide this happiness. You know, there's an interesting thing that is like a real friendship dilemma that you guys were mining, I think, in this episode, which is, one is like, I'm going to sign off on my friend's version of reality. Like, I'm going to say, yes, he did you wrong, or she did you wrong, or this is horrible, or you're the victim here.
我们也当过那种超级幸福的家伙，心想：“我不能在我现在深爱的人面前表现得这么开心。我得把这份快乐藏起来。”你知道的，这有一个有趣的现象，是一个真正的友情困境，我想你们在这一集里挖掘的就是：一方面，我打算认可我朋友对现实的看法。比如，我会说：“没错，他对不起你，或者她对不起你，这太糟糕了，在这里你才是受害者。”
Whatever their idea is, for a long time as your friend, you're like, yes, you have a right to be feeling what you're feeling and I am with you and I hate them for you and with you. But then at a certain point, the better friend act is to say enough. You've got like, I have a very dear friend who was really stuck around some stuff. I don't want to go too into it. But one of our other very dear friends, these are longtime friends, he really risked their friend. by saying, you've got to stop this. Like, you've got to forgive this person. You've got to move on. Yeah. And I really salute this other friend for risking that. It can be very hard sometimes to speak capital T truth to a friend who's really got their stories, you know, set.
无论他们的想法是什么，作为你的朋友，在很长一段时间里，你都会说：“没错，你有权感受到你所感受到的，我和你站在一起，我为你也替他们感到痛恨。”但在某个时刻，更好的朋友的做法是说“够了”。你必须……我有一个非常亲密的朋友，他在某些事情上真的很纠结。我不想说得太具体。但我们另一个非常亲密的朋友，这些都是多年的老朋友，他真的冒着友谊破裂的风险说：“你必须停下来。比如，你必须原谅这个人。你必须继续向前看。”是的。我真的向这位冒着风险的朋友致敬。有时向一个已经把自己的故事“写死”的朋友说出大写的实话，可能会非常困难。
Yeah. And to say, like, this is only hurting you. Yeah. I think Ted was the best friendship Ted exhibit in that episode was when he yelled at Marshall. Yeah. I think that was, it was time. Yeah. That was the power of that structure of seeing the whole summer past, day 56, day 67, blah, blah, blah.
是的。然后说：“这样做只会伤害你自己。”我认为泰德在这一集中展现出的最佳友情时刻，就是他冲马歇尔大吼的时候。是的。我觉得那是时候了。是的。这就是看到整个夏天流逝的那种结构的力量，第56天，第67天，巴拉巴拉。
It's a long fucking time. Yeah. It's the whole summer. It's September now. And it's like, it's almost like Ted is saying in this meta way, like, we've still got to be characters in this show. We've still got to. We've got this show to do. People are watching it.
这他妈是很长一段时间。是的。这是一个整整夏天。现在已经是9月份了。这就像是泰德在以一种元叙事的方式说：“我们还得继续在这个节目里当角色呢。我们还得……我们还有这个节目要拍。观众们都在看呢。”
Also, it's like, it's like a narrative is about action. You're just being a big baby on the floor. We've got to do stuff. We've got to take some action. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I just realized there's a very meta thing. At the beginning where a marshal's going to reach the phone to call Lily and doesn't Ted say, I will punch you in the face?
而且，这就像是……叙事是关于行动的。你只是像个大婴儿一样躺在地板上。我们得做点什么。我们得采取一些行动。对，对，对。我刚意识到这里有一个非常元的梗。在开头，当马歇尔伸手去拿电话准备打给莉莉却被制止时，泰德是不是说：“我要一拳打在你脸上”？
Yeah. And he says, you're a good friend, Ted. Yeah. And, like, he ends up actually kind of punching him in the face and it's him being a good friend, like later. Yeah. You know, that's kind of like the synopsis of what happens in the episode, right? Yeah, it is.
是的。然后马歇尔说：“你是个好朋友，泰德。”是的。然后……他最后真的差不多打了他的脸，而这其实正是他作为一个好朋友的表现，就像后来那样。是的。你知道的，这差不多就是这一集剧情的梗概，对吧？是的，确实如此。
That's right. He needs that punch in the end. He needed that. He needed to be shaken out of this. Yeah. I remember the writer's room. everyone had their breakup story, right? In the writers' room,
没错。他最后确实需要那一拳。他需要那一拳。他需要被这样摇醒。是的。我记得在编剧室里，每个人都有过分手的经历，对吧？在编剧室里
everyone, like that sort of summer passing, that, like, blur of being in a months-long post-breakup, like, depression. Everyone in the writer's room had stuff on that. And I hope this isn't being, like, sharing too much, but, like, you know, Jason Siegel had had a serious relationship when we met him and shot the pilot. He wrote quite a big movie about it,
每个人……那种夏天的流逝，那种经历长达数月的失恋加抑郁的迷糊状态。编剧室里的每个人都有过这方面的经历。我希望这不算分享得太多，但是，你知道的，杰森·席格尔（Jason Segel）在我们认识他并拍摄试播集时，正经历一段认真的恋爱关系。他为此写了一部相当大的电影
so I don't think we're spoiling anything. But just to talk about, like, he was very... That was fresher for him that. It was before he wrote that movie. or maybe he was writing that movie as we were shooting this, but he knew how to lean into that feeling, right? He had been in that feeling not too long before we shot this. You didn't get the feeling like Jason was like would not draw.
所以我觉得我们不算剧透什么。但我想说的是，他非常……对那时的他来说，那段记忆还很新鲜。那是在他写那部电影之前。或者也许在我们拍这一集时他正在写那部电影，但他知道如何融入那种情感，对吧？在我们拍这个之前不久，他正经历着那种情感。你不会觉得杰森是在……假装。
Like Jason knew how to suffer over a relationship ending. That was available to him. Yes. You know, when Barney comes in and one of Neil's great things is like his ability to like pivot. Yeah. Like just pivot. Like he can go one place. It almost is like slaloming down a hill.
就像杰森知道如何为一段感情的结束而痛苦。这种情感对他来说触手可及。是的。你知道的，当巴尼走进来时，尼尔（Neil）最厉害的一点就是他那种应变能力。是的。就是随机应变。就像他可以去任何地方。这几乎就像是在山坡上打回旋滑雪。
You make it like a sharp. turn to clear a gate. Like, he's so good at that. And his, like, real genuine concern for Marshall and then his realization that they're all three single, so he thinks at the same time. And something Neil does in this, but I don't know if he did it in season one.
你做出一个急转弯来绕过一个旗门。是的，他太擅长这个了。他那种对马歇尔发自内心的真正的关心，然后意识到他们三个都是单身，所以他认为……与此同时。尼尔在这里做的一件事，我不知道他在第一季里有没有这样做。
I think he did it a little bit, but he's really leaning into it. When he looks off into the middle distance for these monologues. He really does. Yes, he really does how that. And to him in his head, it's like they're swelling strings.
我觉得他稍微做了一点，但他现在真的全身心投入进去了。当他为了这些独白而把目光投向中景时。他确实这么做了。是的，他真的把这演出来了。在他脑海里，感觉就像是有交响乐团的弦乐在澎湃。
Like this is like a big monologue in a movie that he is delivering. And you always get the feeling like on the cab over. He thought up some of these lines. Like he's so performance. Yeah, Barney's writing his own dialogue. Yeah. In Barney world, Barney's definitely crafting a dialogue. I have a fun fact about that speech.
就像这是一部电影里的大段独白，而他正在慷慨激昂地发表。你总会觉得，在坐出租车的路上。他已经想好其中一些台词了。他的表演欲太强了。是的，巴尼在自己写台词。是的。在巴尼的世界里，巴尼绝对在精心雕琢台词。关于这段演讲，我有一个有趣的冷知识。
First of all, I mean, Neil fucking crushed that speech. Amazing. And that turn at the end where he realized, and his magical ability to know that Ted and Robin hooked up is great. Neil killed that And a fun fact about that speech is it is kind of cribbed from the grapes of wrath I'll explain So we had Fitzgerald in season one
首先，我的意思是，尼尔他妈的把这段演讲演得太绝了。太棒了。最后那个转折，当他意识到并展现出他知道泰德和罗宾滚了床单的那种神奇能力时，简直棒极了。尼尔把这段演绝了。关于这段演讲的一个冷知识是，它其实是抄袭自《愤怒的葡萄》（The Grapes of Wrath）。我会解释的。我们在第一季里用过菲茨杰拉德
Steinbeck in season two Yeah And it was not I will not take credit for that at all And I don't think it was Carter either Greg Malins Who was joining the show at that point Greg Malin's a very funny writer
第二季用了斯坦贝克。是的。而且这不是……我可不敢把这个功劳揽在自己身上。我觉得也不是卡特的主意。格雷格·马林斯（Greg Malins）
executive producer wrote for friend great dude rode for friends for many years and moved up the ranks to the point where he was running friends for at least a couple of seasons, I think. And then we learned he was this huge
当时加入剧组的格雷格·马林斯是个非常有趣的编剧、执行制片人，为《老友记》（Friends）写过剧本，是个很棒的家伙，为《老友记》工作了很多年，并一路晋升到至少担任了《老友记》几季的节目统筹。然后我们得知他是个超级
how much her mother fan. We were huge friends fan. We hired him to come, be kind of like our number two guy on the show in season two. He wasn't on season one. And he came into season two and right away had this great pitch
《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝。我们是《老友记》的超级粉丝。我们在第二季时雇他来做我们在剧中的二把手。他第一季没参与。他第二季一来，立刻就提出了一个绝妙的构思
for this Barney's. We knew we wanted a big Barney speech that ended with Barney that was celebrating them all being single. Thank God, we're all single for the first time together and then realizing Robin, like Ted and Robin hooked up
就是关于巴尼的这段。我们知道我们需要一段宏大的巴尼演讲，以巴尼庆祝他们全部单身作为结束——感谢上帝，我们终于第一次一起单身了——然后突然意识到罗宾……泰德和罗宾滚过床单，然后瞬间泄气。我们知道这个叙事结构。但我们不知道演讲的具体内容是什么，我们当时想：这是第二季的开场，第一个序列，必须他妈的震撼全场。然后格雷格说：“好吧，《愤怒的葡萄》里有这么一段演讲。”我一边说话一边试图把它找出来，其中有一句台词大概是：“在黑暗中，无论哪里有饥饿之人的抗争，有警察殴打某人，或者有饥饿的孩子们在苦笑，我都会在那里。”所以格雷格……格雷格·马林斯不知怎么就把这段演讲记在脑子里了。他说：“如果把这个改成巴尼到处和人上床，怎么样？”我说：“太棒了！”
and deflating. We knew that shape. But we didn't know what the speech was, and we're like, it's the opening of the season two, the first sequence, it needs to fucking kill. And Greg said, well, there's that speech in the Graves of Rath. I'm trying to look it up as we're talking where it's like, I'm just like one line from it is like, in the dark, wherever there's a fight for hungry people, a cop eating up a guy, or kids laughing while hungry, I'll be there. So Greg, Greg Malen somehow had that speech in his head. And he's like, what about that except it's Barney fucking people? And I was like, yes.
然后，我们查阅了《愤怒的葡萄》里的那段演讲，并且……我们基本上是照着那个来建模的。昨晚看这个之前，我已经有很多年没想起过这事了。这感觉就像是：那是《愤怒的葡萄》版。
And, like, we looked up the speech from Grapes of Wrath and, like, we sort of modeled it on that. I hadn't thought of that for so many years before I watched this last night. It was like, that was Gregs of Rath. Yeah. You know, this is a little name-droppy, but it's a fun little thing.
你知道的，这可能有点借名人之嫌，但这是一个有趣的小插曲。我和杰森·拉斯（Jason Mraz）挺熟的。我认识他很久了。他有一首我特别喜欢的很棒的歌，我甚至不知道他有没有发行过，歌名叫《拯救》（Rescue）。他的经纪人告诉他：“你应该向大师偷师。比如从史上最伟大的旋律和作曲家那里偷师。”所以他给我看这首歌《Rescue》其实用的是帕海贝尔卡农（Pachelbel's Canon）的和弦进行。
I'm friendly-ish with Jason Rass. I've known him for a long time. And he has this great song I love that. I don't even know if he's released it called Rescue. And his manager told him, like, you should steal from the greats. Like, steal from, like, the greatest melodies and composers of all time. And so he showed me that this song, Rescue, is the chord progressions of Pocobel's canon.
哦，对。但你永远不会发现。这就像他用了某种地图。他不是唯一这么干的人。是的，是的，是的。但他确实用了这张地图，对吧？而且我觉得，你们……你可以把某种东西嫁接到一个真正行之有效的形式上。我的意思是，这是一种修辞形式。
Oh, yeah. But you'd never know it. It's just like he used this kind of map. He's not the only one that did that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But he used the map, right? And I think, like, you guys, you can graft something on to a form that really works. I mean, it's a rhetorical form.
这几乎就像是一场政治演讲，真的很有那种“是的，我们可以”的感觉。是的，这就是重复，就像一首模式诗。这就好比，如果我们采用这种模式诗，然后做我们自己的版本，它就成了。这就像“怪人奥尔”（Weird Al）那样，对吧？这就好比，让我们拿一个好东西，然后把它变成我们自己的。
It's almost like a political speech that really is, like, yes, we can. Yeah. Yeah, it's the repeated, it's like a pattern poem. And it's like, if we take that kind of pattern poem and we kind of do our own version of it, it's there it is. It's like weird owl, you know? It's just like, let's take something good and make it our own.
是的，我太喜欢了。你这简直是在用“怪人奥尔”的方式翻唱它。你知道在巴尼演讲结束时，当他反应过来，然后看着泰德和罗宾，花了一秒半的时间……那一下击中了我。他说：“哦，你们俩成了。”就像他全明白了。我意识到这一集里还有另一件事要指出来。
Yeah, I love that. And you're weird allying it. You know what struck me at the end of Barney's speech when he figured, and then he looks at Ted and Robin, it takes him a second and a half. And he says, oh, you guys did it. Like he knows. And I realize there's one other thing that I'll point out in this episode.
我觉得那是泰德和马歇尔之间的互动，他们真的有心灵感应。他们确实有。不仅仅是在那些表现心灵感应的时刻。他们对彼此的了解已经如此之深，以至于他们心领神会。他们能够理解言外之意。他们能读懂彼此的肢体语言。他们能读懂他们之间的种种暗示。
I think it's with Ted and, Marshall, they do have telepathy. They do. It's not just in the telepathic moments. They're getting to know each other so well that they get it. They understand unspoken. They can read each other's body language. They can read stuff between them.
我觉得这太迷人了。这是所有这些角色之间正在发展的一种亲密关系的真正表现。他们就是心知肚明。我真的非常喜欢，因为罗宾说：“这就像我们有了个孩子。我们整个夏天都有个孩子。我们才刚在一起。”
And I thought that was fascinating. It's a real gesture of the intimacy that is developing between all of these characters. They just know things. I really like, because Robin says it's like we have a baby. We had a baby all summer. We just got together. we have a baby, his name's Marshall, and like, and I love, I loved that metaphor because Ted is being parental to Marshall. We're seeing, like, young Ted who will someday grow up to have
“我们有个孩子，他叫马歇尔。”而且我喜欢……我喜欢这个隐喻，因为泰德对马歇尔表现出了父爱。我们看到的是……年轻的泰德，他有朝一日长大后会有
these two children parenting Marshall through the summer, and in the end, giving him tough love and being kind of firm and challenging him and using that parenting speed after this summer of comfort. I mean, it's like, when couples get together and they accidentally get pregnant so fast, and they barely, like, that's what Ted and Rob, they're like, we just, us got together, and now we have a baby, a screaming, crying baby on our hands. This is teeny tiny, but one joke that I was disappointed. Every now and again, someone will ask me, like, do you have regrets? Would you go back and, like, change a joke?
这两个孩子。在这个充满舒适感的夏天过后，他在夏天里扮演着抚育马歇尔的角色，并在最后给予他严厉的爱，表现得坚定并向他发起挑战，使用那种为人父母的教育方式。我的意思是，这就像当情侣们在一起时，意外地很快就怀孕了，而他们几乎……泰德和罗宾就是这样，他们就像：“我们刚在一起，现在我们手里就抱著一个婴儿，一个尖叫哭泣的婴儿。这太微不足道了，但有一个笑话让我感到失望。每隔一段时间，就会有人问我：‘你有遗憾吗？你会回去修改一个笑话吗？’”
I did have one of those because I misremembered a joke in this, and I think my misremembering was funnier, and maybe we tried to write it this way and we're told to change it or got a note or something. But you know the joke where Marshall comes out, and he's talking about how, he has a lily shampoo. He's talking about how it smells like lavender and seashells and hope. And it's both comforting and erotic at the same time. And then Robin goes, that's mine.
我确实有过这种想法，因为我记错了一个笑话，而且我觉得我记忆中的版本要好笑得多，也许我们当时试图这样写，但被告知要修改或者收到了某种意见反馈。但你知道那个笑话吗，马歇尔走出来，谈论着……他用的是莉莉的洗发水。他谈到它闻起来有薰衣草、贝壳和希望的味道。它既令人舒心又带点色情。然后罗宾说：“那是我的。”
I thought we wrote it that Ted goes, that's mine. Which is so much funnier. It is funnier. I was heartbroken watching this last night because I've misremembered this for 20 years as the better version of that joke. And I can't remember if we had it that way and we're like told the chance. I don't know what the hell was happening there. But it's still kind of a funny joke.
我以为我们当时写的是泰德说：“那是我的。”这样好笑得多。确实更好笑。昨晚看的时候我心碎了，因为在过去的20年里，我一直把这个笑话更好的版本记错了。我记不清我们当时是不是那样写的，然后被告知要修改。我不知道当时到底发生了什么。但它仍然是个挺好笑的笑话。
It would have been so much funnier if it was Ted's. It's also like, I don't know. It's certainly now. I mean, maybe it wasn't true then. Like, who can tell the difference you know of female and male shampoo at this point? Totally, no, absolutely. I was thinking there must be things in writers' rooms where I thought you guys probably had a really fun time with similarities between the early months of dating and breakups. Like, just like getting an idea and kind of crowd sourcing it and running around, you know, the dry erase board, like getting up all the day.
如果那是泰德的，就会好笑得多。而且这也……我不知道。当然现在来看，我的意思是，也许当时并非如此。现在谁还能分清女用洗发水和男用洗发水的区别呢？完全没有，绝对分不清。我当时在想，在编剧室里肯定有很多这样的时刻：你们可能觉得把约会头几个月的相似之处和分手结合起来是一件非常有趣的事。比如，只要有个灵感，然后大家群策群力，围着白板讨论，把所有的日子都串联起来。
And then picking the best ones, right? Yep, absolutely. That's what that whole form was where you're going through the summer and here to similarities kids. and I love that it's future Ted kind of giving the kids this bit of wisdom, how there's overlaps of these things. That was so much fun to pitch on. Yeah, we found a lot of, we found a bunch of good structures in this one. Like, even like mini structures like that.
然后挑选出最好的那些，对吧？是的，完全正确。这就是那一整套表格的由来，你们在夏天经历过这些，然后发现孩子们有相似之处。我非常喜欢这是未来的老爸在向孩子们传授人生智慧，指出这些事情之间是有重叠的。提出这个创意真的太有趣了。对，我们在这一集中找到了很多不错的结构。就像这种微型结构一样。
Like, that's a minute of the show right there. You know, it's 45 seconds of the show is like that concept. And then that concept, you know, not too much long past that. You're getting another credit card, mystery of it all. And again, another mystery episode, right? This episode becomes a mystery episode, like so many of the great. how much of other episodes, proving my theory that the mini mysteries within this larger series mystery are so many of our best episodes are that. And I think that's why this episode works, because
比如，这直接就是剧中的一分钟内容。你知道，这集里有45秒就是这种概念。然后那个概念，你知道，没过多久。你又拿到了另一张信用卡，这就是它的神秘之处。又是一个悬疑剧集，对吧？这一集变成了一个悬疑剧集，就像许多优秀的剧集一样。这证明了我的一个理论：在这个宏大的系列悬疑中，包含了许许多多的微型悬疑，我们很多最棒的剧集都是这样的。我想这就是为什么这一集能成功，因为
there's a mystery to solve. And Lily is this completely off-screen presence in imaginary land, and this mystery needs to be solved. And I did love that about this one. You know, there's those memes that go around, like, kids, I'm going to tell you a nine-year story that could have taken 15 minutes, Right? Yep. And I understand that, but it's almost like saying, well, you're going to die anyway, so you should just get on with it and kill yourself.
有一个谜题需要解开。而莉莉在想象世界中是一个完全不在场的存在，这个谜题需要被解开。我确实很喜欢这一点。你知道网上流传着那种梗图，比如：孩子们，我要给你们讲一个本可以15分钟讲完的9年长篇故事。对吧？是的。我能理解那种感受，但这几乎就像是在说，反正你横竖都得死，所以你不如直接痛快点，自己了断算了。
Like, there's so much pleasure to be had in the ride and in the storytelling and in the little mini mysteries along the way. Yeah. As opposed to all of those other sitcoms that never wasted any time or took any word sidetrists. They were all business all the time. Oh, just forward action, momentum. of who was the boss?
你看，这个过程本身、讲故事的过程、以及一路上那些小小的微型悬疑，能带给人巨大的快乐。是的。不像其他那些从不浪费时间、也从不拐弯抹角的情景喜剧。它们从头到尾都直奔主题。哦，只有向前的动作和推进。谁是老大？
You know? Yeah, so I think there's, there's each little episode that has its own kind of self-contained little mystery. I mean, there's a reason I think people keep watching it over and over, and that's part of what we're interrogating here. I loved Barney's suicide mimes. They're so disturbing. I can't believe we got him on.
你知道吗？对，所以我认为，这里每一个小插曲都有它自己那种相对独立的微型悬疑。我的意思是，我认为人们一遍又一遍地看这部剧是有原因的，这正是我们现在正在探讨的一部分。我太喜欢巴尼的自杀模仿秀了。它们太让人不安了。我简直不敢相信我们把它播出了。
Like the first one is a gun. The second one is he's hanging himself. The third one is, what's it called when you do the samurai? Sapuku. Sapuku, yeah. Yeah, oh, my God. It's so specific. He's really thought out every beat of how he would disembowl himself.
就像第一个是拿枪。第二个是上吊。第三个是，那个切腹的叫什么来着？切腹。切腹，对。对，哦，天哪。太具体了。他真的把如何剖腹自杀的每一个节拍都想好了。
And you probably, this is another thing that Greg Malins used to say to me is he's like, it's really important for the writers to get to know the actors because you learn more about what you can give them, like what you can, what they, you know. And one of the things I think that you guys started to notice about Neil was he was a physical comedian, like, extraordinary. Like a cartoon, a genius, yeah. Like his precision and his ability to kind of like mime things and turn on a dime and do these little, I mean,
你可能——这也是格雷格·马林斯经常对我说的一句话，他说：编剧了解演员真的非常重要，因为这样你才能更清楚自己能为他们量身打造什么，比如他们的特质……你们开始注意到尼尔的特点之一就是，他是一个极其出色的肢体喜剧演员。就像个卡通人物，天才，对。他的精确度以及他那种模仿事物、瞬间转变并做出这些小动作的能力，我的意思是——
just incredibly specific, virtuosic things. Like, you could feel that, like, and I don't even remember how much direction was in the script. Like, they were probably pretty specific, right? I mean, what he did with the sort of disemboweling himself with a samurai sword was, was a work of art. We did not scripted that.
简直是极其具体、极其精湛的表演。你可以感觉到，而且我甚至不记得剧本里写了多少导演提示。它们可能写得相当具体吧？我的意思是，他用武士刀剖腹自杀的那种表演，简直是一件艺术品。这不是我们写进剧本里的。
I don't know that I would love to. Maybe we wrote that in, but again, if we did, it was better than we could have hoped for. The writing is really sharp in this episode. Like, Jordana, we noticed she was laughing so hard. Oh, good. This is my wife, Jordana, for those of us,
我不确定我是不是愿意。也许我们把它写进去了，但话说回来，如果我们写了，那效果也超出了我们的预期。这一集的台词写得非常犀利。就像乔丹娜，我们注意到她笑得前仰后合。哦，太好了。这是我的妻子乔丹娜，对于刚刚加入我们的观众来说，
just joining us. First time viewer. First time viewer. And she said, she leaned over to me, and she's like, wow, we're laughing like a lot. Oh, that's so good to hear. I was so nervous about this episode at the time. I so wanted it to work, so did Carter.
她是第一次看。第一次看。然后她对我说，她靠向我，然后说：“哇，我们笑得也太多了吧。”哦，听到这个太棒了。当时我对这一集感到非常紧张。我和卡特一样，都极力希望它能成功。
I think that you're starting to see that the kind of comedic landmines and character quirks and stuff that you planted in the first season start to really pay off, like when you come back to, you know, and even, you know, Robin as a gun nut. We learned that in this one.
我想你开始看到，那些你在第一季中埋下的喜剧地雷、角色怪癖之类的东西，现在开始真正产生回报了，比如当你回想起，你知道的，甚至还有，罗宾是个枪械迷。我们在这一集中了解到了这一点。
He calls her a gun nut, and she says, no, I'm a gun enthusiast. Enthusiast. Enthusiast is such a good word. So good. Yeah, that was us finding those other speeds and finding how Kobe can, Kobe, when she warns him not to bet, and Ted's not going to find out. And she's holding the gun.
他叫她枪械迷，而她说，不，我是枪械爱好者。爱好者。爱好者这个词真是太棒了。太棒了。对，那是我们找到了其他的节奏，找到了科比如何，当她警告他不准打赌，而特德不会发现的时候。她手里拿着枪。
Like, finding this feed that Robin is a little bit terrifying at times was amazing. And also, like, the, of course, Ted is not a gun fan. Like, of course, like, that's a great moment of conflict. Like, like, that's going to, you know, their different kind of worldviews and their different political takes, like, it's very smart how that starts to reveal itself. But there was something about this episode, like, I found myself laughing really hard at this episode. Oh, that's so great to hear. I really did. You know what I thought was a great line is when Marshall says, why eat food? It's just going to leave me. And then Ted says, you know, he kind of makes the joke
那种发现罗宾有时有点可怕的节奏，简直太棒了。还有，当然啦，特德不是枪械迷。当然啦，这是一个绝佳的冲突时刻。就像，这将会，你知道的，展示他们截然不同的世界观和政治立场，这开始展现出来的方式非常聪明。但关于这一集有一种感觉，就是我发现自己看这一集时笑得非常厉害。哦，听到这个太棒了。我真的笑了。你知道我觉得哪句台词很棒吗？就是马歇尔说：“为什么还要吃东西？它最终还是会离开我。”然后特德说，你知道的，他把那个笑话
explicit, at least in this scenario, you get to do the dumping. Like, it's such a dumb throwaway joke, but so smart. That was one of my hardest laughs. It was when I forgot about the joke completely. That was one of my hardest laughs of the whole episode. And also Ted's face like, hey, like trying to lighten the mood, you know. I thought there was a great, almost like a pretty iconic Barney line in this episode when he said, when I get sad, I stop being sad and just be awesome instead.
直接挑明了，至少在这种情况下，是由你来甩别人。这就像是一个非常蠢的废话笑话，但又极其聪明。那是让我笑得最大声的笑话之一。当时我完全把这个笑话给忘了。那是整集中最让我捧腹大笑的时刻之一。还有特德的表情，就像是“嘿”，试图缓和一下气氛，你知道的。我觉得这一集里有一句非常棒、几乎堪称标志性的巴尼台词，他说：每当我感到难过时，我就不再难过，转而变得超棒。
True story. Like, that's like a Barney T-shirt line. Like, like it gets quoted all the time as one of the most quoted lines I see. And it's just sort of a throwaway in the middle of this episode. It's so like thrown away. but it caught on. It's also, it's a, it's a kind of monument to repression. Like, it's like, it's weird.
千真万确。这就像是一句可以印在巴尼T恤上的台词。这经常被人引用，我看到这是被引用最多的台词之一。而它在这集中只是随口一说。就是那种漫不经心的随口一说，但它却流行开了。这也是一种对压抑的纪念。就像，这感觉很奇怪。
It's like not quite a healthy thing, but like growing up in the Midwest, like, I get it. I get it. It's not a self-help book, but it also kind of can work for a while. But it was also, you know, we know from season one that he's got this reservoir of emotion that he's sitting on top of that he's put a tie in a suit on top of. So it's both a throwaway funny line that his character revealing. but we'll also come back. Because that can't last.
这算不上是一种多健康的心理，但作为一个在中西部长大的人，我懂。我懂。这虽然不是什么自助心灵书籍，但它在一段时间内确实能起作用。不过，这也——正如我们在第一季中所知道的那样，他的内心其实积压着一股巨大的情感，只是被他强压在领带和西装下面。所以这既是一句无厘头的搞笑台词，也揭示了他的角色性格。但它以后还会再次出现。因为那种状态是无法持久的。
That does not last. That doesn't last forever. And we go on to show that, but of course we didn't know exactly how and when we would show all of those things. And that's what was fun about getting to Robin as a gun nut. I'm like, right, we found that there. We found that there. And we started to know her a little more. And this old man, he must admit, fell in the wheel in New York City. And now, commercials.
那是无法持久的。那不会永远持续下去。我们在后面的剧集中展示了这一点，但当时我们当然不知道我们会通过什么方式、在什么时候把所有这些东西展现出来。而这正是让罗宾成为枪械迷这一设定变得有趣的所在。我想，没错，我们在那里找到了这个设定。我们在那里找到了它。我们开始更深入地了解她了。而这位老者，他必须承认，在纽约市转动了命运之轮。现在，进入广告。
End of commercials. Back to show. You know what's a fun runner in this episode is, uh-oh, already? I know. A little premature ejaculation runner, just for the folks watching an 8.30 on CBS with our kids. But that's another way where Ted has telepathy. He's calling her. Like, he can feel it in the house. Oh, I love that.
广告结束。回到节目。你知道这一集里有一个很有趣的连续笑点吗？——哦，天哪，这么快？我知道。一个关于早泄的连续小笑点，这可是为了那些在晚上8点30分和孩子一起看CBS的观众准备的。但这又是特德展现心灵感应的一种方式。他在给她打电话。就像，他在房子里就能感觉得到。哦，我太喜欢这个了。
I love that. It's kind of like a parent knows that the kid is in danger downstairs, you know? Like, I need to go save them. And he's right. That it really is telepathy. He knew from 50 feet away in a closed door and Marshall's doing it. It really is parental because as a parent, you do have that. You're like, it's too quiet out there.
我太喜欢了。这有点像父母知道楼下的孩子有危险一样，你知道吗？就像，我得去救他们。而且他是对的。这真的就是心灵感应。他在隔着一扇关着的门、相距50英尺远的地方就知道了，而当时马歇尔正在这么做。这确实很有父母的感觉，因为作为父母，你确实会有那种直觉。你会想：“外面太安静了。”
Some shit's gone around. It's not even the noise that calls you. It's the quiet. It's too quiet out there. What was the line Ted says he watched a scary movie? Was that to Robin? Yeah, because, yeah, yeah. No, he said that to Robin was being like Marshall's,
肯定发生什么事了。甚至都不是声音把你叫醒的。是那种安静。外面太安静了。特德说他看了一部恐怖电影，那台词是什么来着？是对罗宾说的吗？对，因为，对，对。不，他对罗宾说，就像马歇尔那样，
He was sleeping on our floor. He was sleeping on the floor. He watched the scary movie. He watched the scary movie. It's like the tough mom and then the pushover. Ted's the pushover dad. Yeah, he's the good cop. She's the bad cop.
他当时睡在地板上。他睡在地板上。他看了一部恐怖电影。他看了一部恐怖电影。这就好像是一个严厉的妈妈和一个好说话的爸爸。特德就是那个好说话的爸爸。对，他是红脸，她是黑脸。
Yeah. Marshall getting ejected from the baseball game and throwing the chili dog. Holy shit. I forgot about that. I forgot about that too. There's so many like viral clips of shit like that really happening at baseball games and sporting the sporting events now these days that I'm like, oh, that feels oddly prophetic. People stealing balls.
对。马歇尔被驱逐出棒球比赛并扔了辣椒热狗。天哪。我都忘了这事了。我也忘了。现在网上有太多这种在棒球比赛和体育赛事中真正发生的类似搞笑短视频了，以至于我觉得，哦，这感觉有一种奇怪的预言性。人们抢夺球。
from kids and also jumbotrons never more in the news than the last couple months you know yeah oh yes yes they have a little cold play retroactive shout out it felt weirdly topical oh i this is a little backstage thing that i remembered so barney has a line about what do you guys watch love actually until your period sync up was that the line and then we laugh and carter came in and gave a note to I think me and Neil, and he said, I want it to be Ray Leota's laugh from Goodfellas. Because remember we both got... Yeah, yeah.
从孩子手里抢球，还有大屏幕，在过去的几个月里比以往任何时候都更常成为新闻，你知道的。哦，对，是的，他们对酷玩乐队（Coldplay）进行了一次迟来的致敬。感觉它有着奇妙的时事性。哦，我——这是一个我记起来的幕后小花絮：巴尼有一句台词是关于“你们看《真爱至上》（Love Actually）看到经期同步为止吗？”是这句台词吗？然后我们笑了，接着卡特走过来，给——我想是给我和尼尔提了一个意见，他说：我希望那是雷·利奥塔（Ray Liotta）在《好家伙》（GoodFellas）里的那种笑声。因为记得我们两个都……对，对。
Like, there's that, like, insane, like, tackle. And he was, like, he was very specific. Like, I just wanted to be Ray Leuton's laugh from Goodfellas. Like, a little too big and a little too crazy. Yeah, that's a great note. And it made... He was absolutely right card, because it made for a great hard cut to that gun firing cutting off that laughter.
就像那种疯狂的、类似猛扑的笑声。他当时的要求非常具体：我只要雷·利奥塔在《好家伙》里的那种笑声。笑得有点过度，也有点疯狂。对，这是一个很棒的意见。它促成了……卡特绝对是对的，因为这制造了一个极佳的硬切，直接切到一声枪响，瞬间打断了那种笑声。
Yeah, that was hilarious. That's hilarious. We just have to talk about funk legend, George Clinton. He's so good in this. He's so hilarious. He's like low-key, a genius actor in addition to being like a toweringly great musician. Yeah, and breaking the fourth wall and turning to camera. Now I'm going to let her play with my hair.
对，太搞笑了。太搞笑了。我们必须谈谈放克音乐传奇人物乔治·克林顿（George Clinton）。他在这一集里演得太棒了。他太搞笑了。除了是一位顶尖的伟大音乐家之外，他低调地还是一个天才演员。对，还有打破第四面墙对着镜头说话。现在我要让她玩我的头发。
I'm going to let her play with my hair. Oh, my God. It's so funny. The funny thing is, here is, I think we were told maybe in some sense of panic to boost the ratings. Again, to give context we had started by the end of season one to lose to that show. where Howie Mandel was opening briefcases full of money with models. We were losing to that.
我要让她玩我的头发。哦，天哪。太搞笑了。有趣的是，当时我们被告知——我想可能是在某种为了提高收视率的恐慌情绪驱使下。再次说明一下背景，到第一季末尾时，我们的收视率开始输给那个节目。
I think we're trying to cast some huge, like, not that George Clinton is not huge, but like some, I don't know, some rock legend that was like beyond what we could get. They wanted Paul McCart, you know, whatever it was. And George, to be clear, George Clinton is incredible get and enduring legend in his own right,
就是豪伊·曼德尔（Howie Mandel）带着模特们打开装满现金的手提箱的那个节目。我们在收视率上输给了它。我想我们当时在试图找一些超级大牌的——倒不是说乔治·克林顿不够大牌，而是某种，我不知道，某种超出我们能力范围的摇滚传奇人物。他们想要保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCart），你知道的，诸如此类的。而乔治，需要说明的是，乔治·克林顿是一个极其了不起的人选，他本身就是一位不朽的传奇，
but so specific and strange, and it's not like where we started. I'm sure the network pitched us all these huge names that were, like, current, like, popular people that are 30, you know what I mean? And to get, like, grizzled old, wonderful Georgianne and Lillian. With eight different colors in his hair? He's the eight different colors in his hair. He has been through some shit, and now he's taken Lily away from Marshall.
但他的风格又极其独特而怪异，这跟我们最初的定位不太一样。我敢肯定，电视网向我们推荐了所有这些超级大牌的名字，都是那种正当红的、流行的人物，大约30岁左右，你知道我的意思吗？而要找来一个饱经沧桑、头发染着八种不同颜色的、美妙的乔治……头发有着八种不同的颜色？他经历过不少风雨，而现在他把莉莉从马歇尔身边带走了。
He's added to his amazing resume. But much like everything with the show, it's like where we landed was actually funnier and cooler than any place. It's where we needed to be. It's so funny. He was so great. and it's whatever the 10 names we didn't get before we got to him, and I mean this in the best way,
这又为他精彩的履历增添了一笔。但就像这部剧中的所有事情一样，我们最终落脚的点实际上比任何方案都更有趣、更酷。这正是我们需要达到的效果。太搞笑了。他太棒了。不管在我们找到他之前错过了哪十个大牌，我是说真的，
it was so right, I'm so thrilled that it was him, he was amazing. And we had a personal connection. I will say we had a personal connection to get him. Erica, the casting assistant, Erica Pennington, I think her mom was part
这实在是太契合了，我太高兴最后能是他了，他太棒了。而且我们和她还有私下的人际关系。我得说，我们能请到他是通过一层私人关系的。埃里卡，选角助理埃里卡·彭宁顿（Erica Pennington），我想她妈妈是
of George Clinton's management team. It was because we were not a hit show. That's what I'm trying to say. We couldn't have gotten Mick Jagger to do that. No one really knew who the fuck we were still. So we needed to call in a favor through directs of contact to George Clinton because we struck out on all the other names.
乔治·克林顿管理团队的一员。这是因为我们当时还不是一部热门剧集。这就是我想表达的意思。我们当时根本请不到米克·贾格尔（Mick Jagger）来客串。当时根本没人知道我们到底是个什么东西。所以我们需要通过直接联系乔治·克林顿的人脉来走后门，因为其他那些大牌我们全都碰壁了。
But we had a personal line to George Clinton, and that's how we got it. I think I'm remembering that correctly. And also just a quick thing to tie it to you, he played at Wesleyan. He did. P. Funk played Wesleyan when Alec and I were in college. P. Funk played a huge show at Wesleyan that was like the spring fling. It was, to this day, legendary show. They're amazing.
但我们有直通乔治·克林顿的私人热线，这就是我们请到他的方式。我想我没记错吧。还有顺便提一下，他在卫斯理大学（Wesleyan）演出过。他确实演过。当我和亚历克上大学时，P-Funk乐队曾在卫斯理大学演出过。P-Funk乐队在卫斯理大学举办了一场盛大的演出，就像春季狂欢节一样。直到今天，那依然是一场传奇般的演出。他们太棒了。
I hope it doesn't seem like anywhere I'm done playing George Clinton. He's fucking great. It was so great. We got him. And I was in a movie. with Catherine Hahn and Juno Temple called Afternoon Delight that had a very uncomfortable strip t-scene to biological speculation, which remains one of my favorite songs. I'm just trying to get in on the George Clinton conversation. I didn't meet him that day. I loved, oh, funk legend, George
希望大家不会觉得我已经对乔治·克林顿夸够了。他他妈的太棒了。真的是太棒了。我们请到了他。我曾和凯瑟琳·哈恩（Kathryn Hahn）以及朱诺·坦普尔（Juno Temple）一起拍过一部名为《下午乐趣》（Afternoon Delight）的电影，里面有一场非常尴尬的脱衣舞戏，背景音乐是《生物推测》（Biological Speculation），这依然是我最喜欢的歌曲之一。我只是想插话聊聊乔治·克林顿的话题。我那天没见到他。我太喜欢了，哦，放克传奇乔治·克林顿。我很高兴你在你的演唱会上发现了人群中的我，并把我拉上台去和你一起跳舞，柯特妮·考克斯（Courteney Cox）风格的。我想知道，对于我们那些深受喜爱的Z世代粉丝来说，
Clinton. I'm so glad you spotted me at your concert and dragged me up on stage to dance with you, Courtney Cox style. And I wonder, for our beloved Gen Z. fans out there, do you guys know what that is a reference to? Because this is like, that's such a Gen X deep cut. This is a pre-Friends Courtney Cox. Yeah. Getting called on stage by Bruce Springsteen in the video for dancing in the dark, right? Correct. Yeah. I think it's her first big thing, Courtney Cox. It's her first big thing she did. Yeah, she's like literally plucked out of the audience and dances adorably with Bruce Springsteen in this very iconic famous video.
你们知道这是在致敬什么吗？因为这绝对是一个X世代的冷门梗。这是属于《老友记》之前的柯特妮·考克斯。对。在布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷（Bruce Springsteen）的歌曲《Dancing in the Dark》的音乐录影带中被叫上台的那个，对吧？答对了。对。我想这是柯特妮·考克斯的第一件大事。这是她做过的不多的早期大事件之一。对，她就像是从观众中被直接挑出来，在这支非常标志性、非常著名的MV里和布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷可爱地跳舞。
But there are a couple of real deep cultural cuts that I'm like, almost like Shakespeare, like the full, like you need like this is what this meant in 1587 or whatever, you know? This podcast episode is airing in October, right? It's October as you're listening to this, mid-October. That means we have passed the 20-year anniversary of the hymium premiere, which as we record,
但其中还有一些真正深层的文化梗，让我觉得，几乎就像莎士比亚的作品一样全面，你需要知道这在1587年或其他什么年份究竟意味着什么，你知道吗？本期播客节目是在十月播出，对吧？当你听到这期节目时正值十月中旬。这意味着我们已经错过了《老爸老妈浪漫史》首播20周年纪念日，在我们录制这期节目时，
this is not here yet here. That's next week. A week from this Friday is the 20 years since it aired underscoring the need to maybe give a few cliff notes here and there 20 years later for what was at the time. Also a reference to something 20 years prior to that that was an 80s music video with Courtney Cox. So yes, we'll try to remember that as we go to name check some of those. And it's just such a funny thing that like that whole sequence is just opening up the cranium of a person who's going insane and making insane connections based on a credit card statement. So he's convinced that there's this ferret involved in. And if the ferret is to mock Marshall who hates ferrets, so she's doing everything to wound
这天还没到。就是下周。从本周五算起的一周后，就是该剧开播满20周年的日子，这也凸显了在20年后，有时确实需要在这里和那里做一些重点提示，解释一下当年这些梗的含义。这也同样是在致敬20年前更早的一个东西，也就是柯特妮·考克斯出演的80年代音乐录影带。所以，是的，当我们接下来提到其中一些名字时，我们会尽量记住这些背景。而且这真的非常搞笑，整段剧情实际上就是在剖析一个正在发疯的人的内心，他仅仅根据一张信用卡对账单，就做出了种种疯狂的联想。所以他确信这里面牵涉到了一只雪貂。如果这只雪貂是为了嘲弄痛恨雪貂的马歇尔，那么她就是在用尽一切手段去伤害
and hurt him. It's accurate, right? When you're imagining that other person you broke up with and the incredible happiness they are experiencing now that you're out of their life, it's, it's come, even though it's completely insane and there's ferrets in George Clinton, it's from a real place. That's why I think it lands, because it is like, your brain spins those things, that person. And the unknownness, like, it's like Jaws. You just don't see the shark for so much of that movie.
和刺痛他。这很准确，对吧？当你想象那个和你分手的前任，想象他们在没有你的生活里正在体验着无与伦比的幸福时，这种感觉——即便这一切完全是疯狂的，里面还夹杂着雪貂和乔治·克林顿——它也是源于真实的情感的。这就是为什么我觉得它能引起共鸣，因为你的大脑确实会围绕着那个人产生各种胡思乱想。那种未知感，就像电影《大白鲨》一样。在那部电影的大部分时间里，你根本看不到鲨鱼。
Like, where's Lily? What is Lily doing in the real world? She's somewhere. She's probably in San Francisco. I mean, we all do it when someone hasn't texted or emailed back. We run through it and we're like, oh, they must be furious about this. Yes. You know, they're angry about this.
就像：莉莉在哪儿？莉莉在现实世界里在做什么？她一定在某个地方。她可能在旧金山。我的意思是，当有人没有及时回复短信或邮件时，我们所有人都会这样。我们会把各种情况在脑海里过一遍，然后想：“哦，他们肯定对此气炸了。”是的。你知道的，他们对此非常愤怒。
I think we spin out. It's real. I love when, I mean, the whole notion. of, like, her identity had been stolen and these are not her charges. Like, such a great reveal of the mystery and that Marshall punches the guy at the hotel room thinking it's her boyfriend.
我觉得我们总是会胡思乱想。这很真实。我特别喜欢——我的意思是，整个概念是：她的身份被盗用了，这些账单根本不是她消费的。——这个悬疑谜底的揭晓实在是太棒了，而且马歇尔在酒店房间里误把别人当作她的男友而揍了那个人。
But I really love the scene. I mean, so obviously, Ted explodes at Marshall in that great thing where he kind of loses it. He can't take it anymore. He has to give him this tough love talking to that came out much harsher, I imagine, than he wanted it to. You had some great stuff in this episode.
但我真的很喜欢那个场景。我的意思是，很显然，特德在那个精彩的桥段中对马歇尔爆发了，他有点情绪失控了。他再也忍受不下去了。他不得不对马歇尔进行了一番严厉的“爱的教育”，我猜，这比他原本预想的要严厉得多。你在这一集里有很多出色的表现。
You had great stuff to play and you leaned into it. Just the protection of Marshall, the arc of protecting Marshall to then running out of the patients to protect Marshall was so... It's like a little bit of a ticking time bomb, right? Like, Ted has this fuse. We're going to get to the point
你有很多精彩的戏份可以发挥，而且你完全沉浸其中。那种保护马歇尔、试图庇护马歇尔的弧光，到最后对保护马歇尔失去耐心的转变，实在是……这有点像一颗定时炸弹，对吧？就像，特德的耐心是有极限的。我们会走到这样一个地步：
where Ted can't even take it anymore and he's going to feel guilty but he was also kind of right. And Marshall thanks him for it. He does snap out of it at the end, sort of. I loved also the reality of the sweet music starts,
特德再也忍无可忍了，他会感到内疚，但他其实也是对的。而马歇尔也为此感谢了他。他最后确实从阴影中走出来了，某种程度上是这样的。我也非常喜欢那种现实感：当温馨的音乐响起，
Ted and Marshall have it out in the bar, the sweet music starts playing and you hard cut out and you go, he wasn't better. He still woke up the next morning and was fucking miserable because that's how it is. That's how breakups are.
特德和马歇尔在酒吧里把话说开，温馨的音乐开始播放，然后镜头直接硬切出去，你会发现：他并没有变好。他第二天早上醒来时依然痛苦得要命，因为生活就是这样的。分手就是这样的。
There was another thing that you guys did that this started to happen a lot, and you can give me more specifics about this, but when he described, Ted walks in, and he describes seeing Marshall for the first time in their dorm room and that confident guy, that absolutely feet up on the wall, you know, and then Marshall says, I was so high, I was high that day.
你们还做过另一件事，从那时起这种桥段开始变得很多，你可以告诉我更多具体的细节。当他描述——特德走进来，他描述了第一次在宿舍里见到马歇尔时的情景，那个自信满满的家伙，把脚完全翘在墙上，你知道的，然后马歇尔说：“我当时嗨大了，我那天嗨大了。”
I was so high, I thought you were the dean, right? Yeah. I don't remember what season is, but we play that. We shot it. We went back and shot that scene. I love when we do that. We did that with the bunk bed joke in season one where it's the top of the bottom bunk moves, the top bunk's going to move to.
“我当时嗨得太厉害了，我以为你是院长呢，对吧？”是的。我不记得那是第几季了，但我们把这段演了出来。我们把它拍了下来。我们特地回头去补拍了那个场景。我特别喜欢我们做这种回溯的时候。我们在第一季中也做过类似的事情，关于上下铺的笑话，上下铺移动时，上铺也会跟着动。
And these jokes that we just had stayed with us, we said, why don't we see that someday? That is the gift of being on for long enough that you can find a way back to show that joke that you said happened. And we did. We did later. I'm blanking on what season at the moment. When you rewatch the series,
这些笑话一直留在我们脑海里，我们当时说：“为什么我们以后不把这个画面拍出来呢？”这就是能拍足够长时间的剧集所带来的福利，你可以找到一种方式回过头去，把你们之前说过的那个笑话实景展现出来。而我们确实这么做了。我们在后来拍了。我一时想不起来是哪一季了。当你重温这部剧时，
people probably remember, people probably remember the scene where he says, oh, I thought you were the dean. You're not the dean, right? and Ted is giggling because he's eating a sandwich. Yeah. They probably remember that. Then they go back and watch it.
观众们可能还记得，观众们大概都还记得那个场景，他说：“哦，我以为你是院长。你不是院长吧？”而特德一边吃着三明治一边咯咯直笑。是的。他们可能还记得那个。然后他们回头去看第一季。
And first episode of season two, he says, oh, I was so high, I thought you were the dean. And they're like, oh, yeah, we end up seeing that later. Like, you can watch this show almost backwards and have delight in it the way, you know. But they have this great scene at the hotel that I thought was just, every once in a while, you would write a scene for me or Jason that I was like, this is a real fun gift. And I think Jason and I really appreciated those scenes where we could,
而在第二季的第一集里，他说：“哦，我当时嗨得太厉害了，我以为你是院长。”然后观众就会恍然大悟：“哦，对了，我们后来真的看到那个画面了。”就像，你几乎可以倒着看这部剧，并从中获得乐趣，正如……但他们在酒店里有一场非常精彩的对手戏，我觉得，每隔一段时间，你们就会为我和杰森写一场戏，让我觉得：这真是一个超级有趣的礼物。我想杰森和我真的非常感激那些场景，在那些场景里我们可以——
just like, be best friends in a way, not under the harsh glare of Barney. But to be the friends that had been best friends since they were 18, you know? I love the line, you can't let Lily steal your identity the way that guy stole hers. Yeah. It's so wonderful. That's my favorite line of the whole episode, I think. The way it ended, I mean, it was kind of like a beautiful, heartbreaking cliffhanger. You know, Marshall's on the road to healing his busted heart.
就像是，以一种真正好朋友的方式相处，而不是沐浴在巴尼那严厉的目光下。而是去展现那些从18岁起就一直是挚友的朋友关系，你知道吗？我特别喜欢那句台词：“你不能让莉莉偷走你的身份，就像那个家伙偷走她的身份证一样。”是的。太精彩了。我想这大概是我整集中最喜欢的台词了。它的结尾，我的意思是，感觉就像是一个美丽而又让人心碎的悬念。你知道的，马歇尔正在走上治愈破碎之心的道路。
The gang is together. They're having, like, a great laugh. in McLaren's. And then we spot Lily through that window wanting to come in, but also something keeping her and probably seeing Marshall, you know, not doubled over in agony. But maybe the gang moved on without me. Like, we never want people to move on, you know. We don't want life to go on without us. That's a, that's a tough thought. So much of how I met her mother was a kind of withholding of information until it was time to learn it and in the most satisfying way to learn it. When When Lily sees, like, Marshall, he's having a good night.
这帮朋友聚在了一起。他们在麦克拉伦酒吧里开怀大笑。然后我们透过窗户看到了莉莉，她想进来，但又有什么东西在拉扯着她，她大概看到了马歇尔并没有——并没有痛不欲生、双倍折磨。而是也许朋友们没有我也能过得很好……就像，我们永远不希望人们抛下我们继续生活，你知道的。我们不希望生活在没有我们的情况下继续前行。这是一个艰难的想法。在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中，有很大一部分内容都是通过隐瞒信息，直到真正该揭晓的时候，再以最令人满意的方式将之呈现出来。当莉莉看到马歇尔时——他正过着愉快的夜晚。
He's at fun with his friends in the bar, and he's laughing. And she sees him laughing. She sees him okay. And she has no idea the months of agony he's been in. You know, really smart, really smart storytelling. Yeah, he seems okay. And maybe that means he doesn't need me to walk through this door. What does it mean that he seems okay?
他和朋友们在酒吧里玩的很开心，而且他在笑。她看到他在笑。她看到他一切都好。而她根本不知道他已经经历了数月的痛苦折磨。你知道的，非常聪明的叙事手法，非常聪明。是的，他看起来还不错。也许这意味着他并不需要我推门走进去。他看起来还不错，这到底意味着什么呢？
And she can't quite do it. The end of that episode is one of my favorite moments in season two when you see Lily. And you have that great talking about needle drops. You talk about the music there, that amazing cover of Boys Don't Cry by Grant Lee Phillips, which was pitched to us by Andy Gowan, our music supervisor. Sometimes Carter and I or Josh or somebody would have the idea for a great song. This was very much Andy Gowan's pitch. Boys Don't Cry, pushing in on that table, pushing past that table of our gang to find Lily in that window. She almost comes in.
而她却迟迟无法推开那扇门。那一集的结尾是我在第二季中最喜欢的时刻之一，当你看到莉莉出场时。你们刚才谈到了音乐切入（needle drops）。你们谈到了那里的音乐，那是安迪·高恩（Andy Gowan）——我们的音乐总监——向我们推荐的格兰特·李·菲利普斯（Grant Lee Phillips）翻唱的极其美妙的《Boys Don't Cry》。有时候卡特、我或是乔什会想出一首好歌的创意。但这个绝对是安迪·高恩的主意。《Boys Don't Cry》，镜头推向那张桌子，穿过我们这帮朋友坐的桌子，最终在窗户那里找到了莉莉。她几乎就要进来了。
She's not ready. She turns away. I just remember in the edit room getting chills when we were putting that together and feeling like, this is going to work. We have a season two. There's stuff here, like, right? You've done one season of TV. You don't know what else is going to happen past that. We were first-time showrunners.
但她还没准备好。她转身走开了。我只记得在剪辑室里把这些拼接在一起时，浑身起鸡皮疙瘩，心里觉得：这绝对行得通。我们有第二季了。这里面有货，对吧？你制作了一季电视剧。你根本不知道接下来会发生什么。我们是第一次当剧集运作人。
We knew we had stuff there. We knew we had a condition that would give us six, eight, ten episodes of that season two. And it just felt like rocket fuel there. I want to see episode two at the end of that episode. It had that cliffhangery thing of like, oh, shit, how does this, how do they get back together here? How does the gang get back together? Well, let me explain another slight change that's happening in season two. We had a bunch of bonus episodes for season one.
我们知道手里有存货。我们知道我们有一种能够支撑第二季再拍6集、8集、10集的底气。那种感觉就像是火箭燃料一样。那一集演完后，我迫不及待地想看第二季的第二集。它有一种悬念感，就像：哦，天哪，这俩人接下来该怎么破镜重圆？这帮朋友到底要怎么重新聚在一起？好吧，让我来解释一下第二季中发生的另一个微小变化。我们在第一季中有很多额外加拍的剧集。
We're going to still do a few, perhaps, but in an effort for Craig and I to be able to spend more time with our families, we're going to be doing less bonus episodes. But we're going to try to retain the spirit of those bonus episodes, which were, of course, called general questions general questions all right still suck at bath here we are just move through it we're going to have this the inability to sync this up is not it's not human error it's technological it's technology there's just a little anyway we are we are going to do our general questions general questions it's a like you're it's your i was like i was i was i hate that it leads to finger pointing and divisiveness within the group that's my regret about
我们接下来可能还会做几集，但为了让克雷格和我能够花更多时间陪家人，我们将减少额外加拍的剧集数量。但我们会努力保留那些加拍剧集的精神内核，当然，它们以前被称为“常见问题解答”、“常见问题解答”。好吧，这里的录音还是有点出问题，没关系，我们继续。这种无法同步的问题不是人为错误，是技术问题，是技术原因。总之，不管怎样，我们还是要进行我们的“常见问题解答”。“常见问题解答”感觉就像是……我当时觉得——我讨厌这种会导致团队内部互相指责和产生分歧的做法，这是我感到后悔的地方……
We're going to be doing that right now. So, Alec, take it away. What do you have for us? Absolutely. So you can find us at how we made your mother.com. Hit contact. You could send in a voice message. You could send in an email.
我们现在就要开始这个环节了。所以，亚历克，请开始吧。你给我们准备了什么？没问题。大家可以在 how I met your mother.com 找到我们。点击“联系我们”。你可以发送语音留言。你可以发送电子邮件。
You could fill out a form. Yes. And also, by the way, these can be questions. These can be observations. And what we really like to hear, especially in the voice notes, is tell us what how I met your mother means to you, how you discovered it, how it changed your life, how, why you keep watching it, who you've, you know, turned on to the show, we want to hear all those stories. We love them. And, you know, on Instagram, I mean, I mean, there have been so many
你可以填写表格。是的。另外，顺便说一句，这些既可以是提问，也可以是观察心得。我们最喜欢听到的——特别是在语音留言中——是大家告诉我们《老爸老妈浪漫史》对你意味着什么，你是怎么发现这部剧的，它如何改变了你的生活，你为什么一直在看它，你把这部剧安利给了谁，我们很想听到所有这些故事。我们太喜欢它们了。而且，你知道的，在Instagram上，我的意思是——多年来，
years of people posting so many clips and memes and things that have sort of kept Himium alive. And thank you to everyone there. And we are, of course, on the social media at How We Made Your Mother. And on our Instagram is where we solicit your questions, also on the How We Made Your other fan club page on Facebook. So from the internet, Spencer Mattson says, asks, what were some of the lessons you learned while filming or writing season one that you knew you weren't to implement in season two? Did you have to do any major pivoting?
人们发布了数不清的短视频、梗图以及各种让《老爸老妈浪漫史》保持活力的内容。非常感谢大家。当然，我们在社交媒体上的账号是 @HowWeMadeYourMother。大家可以在我们的 Instagram 上提交你们的问题，也可以在 Facebook 的“老爸老妈浪漫史粉丝俱乐部”页面上留言。来自网上的斯宾塞·马特森（Spencer Mattson）提问说：在拍摄或编写第一季时，你们学到了哪些教训，并且知道绝不能在第二季中重蹈覆辙？你们是否做过任何重大调整？
Major pivoting. This early in the series, based on how something in the first season was received. Well, I touched upon this a little bit. We were given a bit of a warning not to be too serialized, And I think we just didn't do it. We just, we sort of said, yes, okay, we'll take a look at that. But we didn't, we knew what, we knew the show's power was serialization. And the fact that the emotional through land kind of kept going.
做出重大调整。在剧集刚开播的这个阶段，根据第一季某些内容的播出反响来进行调整？嗯，我刚才稍微提到过这一点。我们当时得到过一些警告，告诫我们不要把剧集做得太连贯（serialized），
And if you look at this episode, we take you all the way through the summer. We take you all the way through the emotional journey of the characters. I don't think, I think the biggest lesson was not to, was not to cave in and worry too much about that, was to think the fans will find this. This will find people who get it. Thank God. Thank you to the fans. Thank you to everyone who's listening to this and who watched the show because we did find you. The show did find you. And I'm proud to say I think we kept, we stayed true to the spirit of what we wanted to do with this show.
我想我们当时根本没理会。我们只是说：好吧，我们会考虑一下的。但我们心里有数，我们知道这部剧的强项就在于连续性。在于情感主线在不断延续。如果你看这一集，我们会带着你经历整个夏天。我们会带着你经历角色们的情感旅程。我不认为——我觉得最大的教训就是不要妥协，不要过多地为之担忧，而是坚信粉丝们会发现这一点。这会找到那些真正懂它的观众。谢天谢地。感谢粉丝们。感谢所有收看这档播客以及观看这部剧的人，因为我们确实找到了你们。这部剧确实找到了你们。我很自豪地可以说，我认为我们保持并忠于了我们制作这部剧的初心。
I think if we learned anything, it was like, let's dig deeper into these characters. Like we find this other weird trait of Robin in this episode, like along the way. And we find other, we just kept digging deeper into these characters and these actors. What these actors could do and these relationships and keeping, digging deeper into their history and connection, I think that was like, that was definitely something we did more of and wanted to do more of in season two. But we didn't want to mess with kind of the heart and soul of the show, which it is serialized. It just is. Josh, was there anything as an actor who now, okay, you're in season two, there's a little, maybe a little more of a, you could breathe out, you're actually doing this. This is staying on TV for a while. and with that aside, you can lean in a little more?
我想如果我们学到了什么，那就是：让我们更深入地挖掘这些角色。就像我们在这一集中发现了罗宾的另一个怪癖一样。我们发现了其他特质，我们只是不断地深入挖掘这些角色和演员。挖掘这些演员的潜力以及他们之间的关系，并不断深入挖掘他们的历史和情感联系，我认为这绝对是我们做得更多、并且希望在第二季中做得更多的事情。但我们不想破坏这部剧的核心与灵魂，那就是它是一部连续剧。它本来就是。乔什，作为一名演员，现在——好吧，你到了第二季，压力或许有所释放，你可以稍微喘口气了，你们真的在做这件事。这部剧将在电视上长盛不衰。
Was there a pressure valve released a little bit for you? Or was it the opposite? It was, oh, we're doing this now. Is it more pressure? No, I think it was less in as much as I knew they were not going to replace me with another guy to play the role. I felt like some measure of job security. I mean, we were still, you know, we were still season to season.
抛开这些不谈，你可以更加投入其中了吗？你心中的压力阀稍微释放了一点吗？还是说恰恰相反？释放了一些，至少我知道他们不会换另一个演员来演这个角色了。我感觉到了一定程度的工作安全感。我的意思是，我们当时仍然——你知道的，我们依然是一季一季地续签。
We weren't getting two season pickups. We were very dependent. We didn't even know if we'd get a back nine in season two at this point, right? Like, we knew we had 13. Correct. Are they going to air all 13? You got to, you know, you got to stay in the zone where they're still feeling good about it. I think that I felt really good about where Ted was.
我们并没有拿到两季连签的合同。我们非常依赖收视率。我们当时甚至不知道在第二季的时候能不能拿到后9集的预订，对吧？就像，我们当时只确定有13集。没错。他们会把这13集全播完吗？你必须——你知道的，你必须保持在安全区内，让电视台对这部剧继续保持信心。我觉得我对特德当时的状态感到非常满意。
I mean, it's certainly, like, even though it's an, you know, you're an actor, like, it's more fun to play the wiser, you know, steadier character in terms of, I mean, it can be fun to play despair and all that stuff. But I liked that Ted didn't have to be, at least in this episode, the person who was punched in the face or left at the altar, like he got to really get the girl, he got to be the good friend. Like, I thought Ted's virtues were really on display in this episode, and I think that's why I liked it so much,
我的意思是，当然，就像——即使你是个演员，扮演那个更睿智、更稳重的角色其实更有趣，当然扮演绝望之类的状态也很有趣。但我喜欢特德不必——至少在这一集中——成为那个被扇耳光或在婚礼上被抛弃的人，他真正追到了女孩，他成为了一个好朋友。我觉得特德的美德在这一集中得到了充分的展现，我想这也是为什么我这么喜欢这一集的原因，
was because I didn't have to open a vein, you know? Yeah, yeah, and that's another thing we learned. We put the focus on Marshall. Marshall. Marshall is the focus of the romantic quandary in this episode and in this opening arc of Season 2. And that was something we wanted to do. He said it was the spotlight was on Ted all through season one. Let's get Ted with Robin and let's take a look at the pain and struggles of somebody else here for a minute. And that was, that was exciting. It was exciting because it was a new move. And we couldn't do that when Marshall and Lily were just super couple. We needed to shake them up a bit there. At Sprat-T asks, Josh looks more tan in the season premiere. How'd you spend your time away? You know, it's so funny, I have very vivid memories of my second season hiatus, but the first season hiatus in between one and two. Oh, I know what I was. I did a, I believe I did a play in Poughkeepsie at the New York stage and film up at Vassar, which is a theater that I have worked with since I was like in college. I'm almost sure I did a play there that summer. So I was just, you know, I was an state, New York, doing theater, and going to the tanning bed many times throughout the summer. What's funny is you're tanning, you got very tan in the half hour after you came in from the rain
因为我不需要剖心沥血，你知道的？对，对，这也是我们学到的另一课。我们将焦点放在了马歇尔身上。马歇尔。马歇尔是这一集以及第二季开篇主线中浪漫困境的焦点。这也是我们想做的事情。正如他所说，整个第一季聚光灯都打在特德身上。让特德和罗宾在一起，然后花点时间来看看其他人的痛苦和挣扎。这真的很让人兴奋。这很让人兴奋，因为这是一个全新的举措。当马歇尔和莉莉还是一对超级情侣时，我们是无法做到这一点的。我们需要稍微打破他们一下。来自 Sprat-T 的网友提问：乔什在季首播里看起来更黑了，你离开的那段期间是怎么过的？你知道这太有趣了，我对第二季开播前的那个假期有着非常鲜明的记忆，但对第一季和第二季之间的那个假期……哦，我知道我当时在干嘛了。我当时——我相信我在波基普西（Poughkeepsie）参加了一场戏剧演出，那是瓦萨学院（Vassar）的纽约舞台与电影项目，那是一个我从大学时期就一直合作的剧院。我几乎可以肯定那个夏天我在那里演了一场戏。所以当时我只是——你知道的，我在纽约州北部演戏剧，整个夏天去了很多次美黑床。有趣的是，你去了美黑，结果在从雨中走进门廊后的半小时内，肤色看起来变得非常深。
on the stoop. That's the weird thing about needing to sort of play that continuity. It's like, everyone looks a little different. The apartment looks a little different. I have, people often say that I look tan. I think that if I get a little bit of sun, I kind of brown up, you know, I don't burn very easily, and it's always a little shocking to people. Boy, are we different. Yes, this is, this just shows that two different species can be friends, Craig. The iris and the Jews don't share the overlap there. At Ryan Schwartz TV says, it's supposed to be the same day, but the brown couch from season one has been swapped for the red couch in the season two premiere. Why the change? Okay, I'll tell you. One, we got a bunch of notes at the end of season one, and a bunch, some of them
这就是需要维持连戏所带来的怪异之处。就像，每个人看起来都有点不同。公寓看起来也有点不同。我经常听人说我看起来晒黑了。我想如果我稍微晒一点太阳，我的肤色就会变成棕色，你知道的，我非常不容易晒伤，而且这总是让其他人感到有些惊讶。天哪，我们俩太不一样了。是的，这正说明了两个不同的物种可以成为朋友，克雷格。爱尔兰人和犹太人在这方面可没有什么重叠。来自 @Ryan Schwartz TV 的网友说：这本来应该是同一天发生的事，但第一季里那个棕色沙发在第二季首播里被换成了红色沙发。为什么要做出这个改动？好吧，我来告诉你。第一，我们在第一季末尾收到了一堆意见反馈，其中有一堆——有些是我们认同的。我们不想把这部剧改成非连续剧。我们想保持它的连贯性，但我们确实收到了反馈。我想我们甚至可能是从帕姆·弗赖曼（Pam Fryman）那里收到的意见，或者大家基本上都达成了共识。第一季从视觉上看，那个公寓看起来有点黑。我想我们——卡特和我希望它看起来不要像《老友记》那种华丽、闪亮的公寓，那种又大又奇怪、带有紫色调、摆满霓虹色物品的感觉。我们希望它更像是一个真正的纽约公寓。虽然它还是有点大。但我们希望它是一个合理的纽约公寓。我想我们大概引导我们的布景设计师
we agreed with. We didn't want to un-serialize the show. We wanted to keep it that way, but we did get it. I think we got a note from the network. It may have even been from Pam Fryman, too, or everybody just sort of agreed. Season one, visually, that apartment looks a little dark. And I think we, Carter and I wanted it to be like not the fancy, shiny, like the friend's apartment, huge and this sort of weird, like that purple-y kind of like, lots of like almost neon-colored things. We wanted it to be more like, this is a New York apartment. It's still too big. But we wanted it to be a plausible New York apartment. I think we probably steered our set designer
以及他的团队朝着这个方向努力：让我们把它调得稍微质朴一点。它不需要看起来金光闪闪。它不需要带有霓虹感。我想我们可能把色调稍微调得有点过火了。第一季看起来确实有点阴暗。沙发有点暗。墙壁有点暗。我们决定把所有东西都提亮一点。
and his team towards like, let's grid it up a little bit. It doesn't need to look shiny. It doesn't need to look neon. And I think we might have gone a few clicks too far. Season one does look a little dark. The couch is a little dark. The wall's a little dark. We decided to just brighten everything up.
和他的团队倾向于稍微加点网格感。它不需要看起来那么光鲜亮丽。它不需要霓虹闪烁。我觉得我们可能做得有点过头了。第一季确实看起来有点黑。沙发有点暗。墙壁有点暗。我们决定把所有东西都调亮一点。
And we did it, hoping no one would notice. But, of course, in the interim, people are like, why the fuck is there a different couch from when they left of the apartment the night before? It's also like you were depending on four months of amnesia for people. Right. It wasn't on streaming.
我们做到了，希望没人注意到。但当然，在这期间，大家都在想：为什么他们前一晚离开公寓时用的沙发，跟现在这个完全不一样？这就像是你们觉得观众会有四个月的失忆症一样。没错，当时又没有流媒体。
You hadn't seen how much a mother since May, now it's September. People literally go from episode 22 of season one right into episode and you're like, why is the couch different? Why is the couch different, bitch? Yeah. We've heard this a lot and we will continue to hear it.
你从五月份之后就没看过这剧了，现在已经是九月份。大家看剧都是直接从第一季第22集连着看下一集，然后你就会想：为什么沙发不一样？这沙发为什么不一样，碧池？是的，我们听过很多次这种吐槽，而且以后还会继续听到。
It's a great question. It is a great question. I never knew that, though. It was my goddamn fake apartment and I didn't know it was a new couch. All right, here's a little BSL. BSL. What does that word come from?
这是一个好问题。确实是个好问题。不过我以前根本不知道这事。那可是我该死的假公寓，而我居然不知道换了新沙发。好了，接下来是一个小小的 BSL。BSL？这个词是怎么来的？
I think it's BTS mixed with ASL, which I'm always thinking about. Sorry, here's a little BTL. Behind sign language. My goodness. A little behind the scenes question from at Keenan 99. Okay. Do the actors in the background of bar and restaurant scenes actually have conversations? It seems like they mouth real words but have silent conversations.
我觉得这是 BTS 混合了 ASL，我一直在琢磨这个。抱歉，这里是一个小小的 BTL。Behind sign language（手语幕后）。天哪。这是一个来自 @Keenan99 的幕后小问题。好的。酒吧和餐厅背景里的背景演员真的在对话吗？他们看起来像是在用真词对口型，但其实是在进行无声的对话。
How does that work? Literally what you just said. That's what it is. Your question answered itself, and yes, it's weird. It's generally the second AD who kind of is in charge of the background. The second AD? Generally the second AD. Extra points.
那是怎么运作的？字面意思，就像你刚才说的。就是这样。你的问题自己回答了，而且是的，这很诡异。通常是第二副导演（2AD）负责管背景演员。第二副导演？通常是第二副导演。加分项。
Generally. And it was Chris, right, who was our second. Oh, maybe it was the second second second. I can't remember there's a second second assistant director. But they're ordered sometimes quite harshly, like, we can hear your whispering. Like, they really have to mouth conversations. They really have to mind it. It must be the most awkward job.
通常是。而且是我们当时的第二副导演克里斯对吧？哦，也许是第二副导演的助手。我不记得了，有个第二助理导演。但有时他们指挥得还挺严厉的，比如：“我们能听到你们在窃窃私语。”真的，他们必须假装在聊天，真的必须靠哑剧表演。这绝对是世界上最尴尬的工作。
in the world to show up and sit with a stranger you were just paired with pretending to talk silently to each other. But there were a couple people that, some of them were like UCLA students or like people that would show up like through the years that were like bar regulars. I'm thinking of a couple. There were a couple women that were just like really cool and they were always kind of in the bar like maybe half, three quarters of the seasons. And we got to know them because you're sitting around eating checks mix and drinking fake beer. And they were lovely. So shout out to the background actors. I always thought this job is actually harder than my job.
来到片场，和一个刚认识的陌生人坐在一起，假装无声地对口型聊天。不过也有几个人，其中有些人是加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的学生，或者是一些多年来一直出现、就像酒吧常客一样的人。我想到了好几位。有几位女性真的超酷，她们总是出现在酒吧里，大概待了半个到四分之三个季度。我们和她们熟络起来，因为大家就坐在那儿吃咸酥零食、喝假啤酒。她们非常可爱。所以向背景演员致敬。我一直觉得这份工作其实比我的工作还要难。
Like, this is a very difficult job. It's not an easy job. And at one point, Conan O'Brien did that job on our show. Yeah, we'll get to that. But, yeah. And finally, a bigger question to end with here is at Camor. At Camor says, how much of season two was planned when you ended season one as you did?
就像，这是一份非常艰难的工作。这可不容易。而且有一段时间，柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）在我们的节目里做过那份工作。对，我们待会儿会聊到。但是，对的。最后，以一个更大的问题来结束这里的问答，@Camor 问：“当你们以那样的方式结束第一季时，第二季有多少内容是已经计划好的？”
Was it a vague outline, or was it more we've set ourselves up? Let's see what comes next. It was more than that. It wasn't let's set ourselves up and see what comes next, but it certainly wasn't meticulously plotted out. I think you're looking for conditions to play. What can give us some rocket fuel for a bunch of episodes? Marshall and Lilly break up, Ted and Robin get together.
是一个模糊的大纲，还是说“我们已经给自己挖了坑，看看接下来会发生什么”？比那要多。不是“让我们设好局然后看接下来发生什么”，但也绝对不是经过缜密规划的。我觉得你是在寻找可以发挥的情境。什么能为一堆剧集提供火箭燃料？马歇尔和莉莉分手，泰德和罗宾在一起。
That's a condition we can play. We can get, and then how do we have fun and be really interesting within that? How do we find the twist in terms of that? But if you set out that condition, you're just kind of getting the raw material, kind of like the fuel and the rocket, and then navigating where that fuel takes you is the next step. And we probably, you know, over the summer as we were starting to break and write those scripts, we got more like plotting the navigation points on that journey.
这是一个我们可以发挥的情境。我们可以得到……然后在其中如何玩得开心、变得非常有趣？如何在其中找到转折点？但如果你设定了那种情境，你其实只是在获取原材料，就像火箭里的燃料一样，然后顺着燃料带你去哪里就是下一步。而且可能，你知道的，在夏天我们开始构思和编写这些剧本时，我们更像是在那段旅程中绘制导航点。
But we knew, I think we gave ourselves a gift at the end of season one, even though season one ends sad and bittersweet, it was a gift to our future selves because we had a story to tell. We had to dig our way out of that problem. Can I ask you, Craig? So by the time we come back, like August, I don't remember, mid-August. let's say, early August, mid-August. You guys were handed episode one.
但我们知道，我觉得我们在第一季结束时送了自己一份礼物，尽管第一季的结局很悲伤、苦乐参半，但这给我们未来的自己送上了一份礼物，因为我们有一个故事要讲。我们必须从那个麻烦中把自已挖出来。我可以问你吗，克雷格？所以等到我们回来的时候，比如八月份，我不记得了，八月中旬左右，比如说，八月初、八月中旬。你们拿到了第一集剧本。
How many episodes deep are you into the writing? How many episodes have you broken? Like, where are you at that point? When you show up to that first, when the actors show up to that first table read in whatever was late August or whatever it would be, if I remember. I think it was a little early.
你们的剧本写到第几集了？你们构思了多少集？到了那个阶段，你们进展到哪一步了？当你们出现在第一次，当演员们出现在八月底（无论具体是哪一天，如果我没记错的话）的第一次围读时。我觉得稍微早了一点。
It was like mid-August, maybe, yeah. A little earlier, early August. We would hope to be at like six scripts, maybe five or six scripts written or degrees of written, and then the outline and the shape for a few past that. And then it just slowly, I was thought of it as like, the season of a TV is like Pac-Man eating these pellets. Okay, that episode got written and shot.
大概是八月中旬吧，是的。稍微早一点，八月初。我们希望已经写好了大概六个剧本，也许是五到六个写完的剧本，或者不同完成度的剧本，然后往后的几集有大纲和雏形。我一直把这比作：一部电视剧的一季就像吃豆人（Pac-Man）在吃那些小圆点。好的，那一集写好了也拍完了。
That's a pellet. And it's just coming, coming, coming. There's this thing got to bite of eating them up. And you're trying to stay as far ahead of that as you can. I realize I'm making us the ghosts in Pac-Man or something. I don't know. The metaphor is falling apart. But, yeah, we would always,
那就是一个小圆点。然后它们不断地来、不断地来。有这么个东西得一口一口把它吃掉。而你正试图尽量保持在它的前面。我意识到我把自己比作吃豆人里的鬼魂什么的了。我不知道。这个隐喻快说不下去了。但是，是的，我们总是……
you'd want to have six scripts and a couple outlines or else you'd feel really screwed. But by the time we show up, that's the most comfortable you as the showrunner is going to feel, because you're the most ahead of it you'll ever be. Like, you're never going to be six episodes ahead the rest of the season. No, you're going to just watch that catch up to you. Watch the devouring Pac-Man Monster catch up and eat up those episodes. And, yeah, it's invigorating, shall we say. It is a marathon run at a sprint pace.
你会希望手里有六个剧本和几个大纲，否则你会觉得彻底完蛋了。但当我们出现时，作为剧集运作人，那是你感觉最舒服的时候，因为这是你整个季度里领先进度最多的一次。就像，在接下来的整个季度里，你再也不会领先六集了。不，你只会看着它追上你。看着那个吃豆人怪兽追上来，把那些剧集都吃掉。而且，是的，可以说这很令人振奋。这是一场以冲刺速度进行的马拉松。
Yeah, awesome. 24 episodes. I think we did 22 in season two. and like when we became more successful, we started getting 24, but 22 is plenty. So we like to end a lot of these episodes with a letter that's been sent in to how we made your mother.com to contact.
对，太棒了。24集。我想我们在第二季做了22集。当我们变得更成功时，我们开始拿到24集，但22集就足够了。所以我们喜欢用一封寄给 HowIMetYourMother.com 联系邮箱的信来结束许多这样的剧集。
And we got a delightful, wonderful letter from Sophie in Germany. And again, if you want to send one in, even if it doesn't make it on the air, which it might, please let us know what the show means to you and anything else you want to share with us about. We love it. It's so nice. It's so great. So this one says, hi, my name is Sophie. I am 15 years old and I live in Germany. I discovered how I met your mother pretty precisely a year ago. I was alone on a nine-hour
我们收到了一封来自德国苏菲的令人愉快、精彩的信。再说一次，如果你想寄信来，即使它没有在节目中播出（虽然也有可能），也请让我们知道这部剧对你意味着什么，以及你想和我们分享的任何其他事情。我们爱死它了。太棒了。太好了。所以这封信写道：嗨，我叫苏菲。我15岁，住在德国。我大约在一年前发现了《老爸老妈浪漫史》。当时我独自一人坐了九个小时的火车
train ride back home from Berlin. I logged into the train Wi-Fi and a website popped up with hundreds of movies and series. For some reason, I decided to click on how I met your mother, not knowing how much I would fall in love with this show and how it would change me. I am someone who worries a lot about their future. I feel like I am missing out on all my teenage experiences, not having kissed anyone yet, or feeling like anyone will ever fall in love with me.
从柏林返回家中。我登录了火车的Wi-Fi，弹出一个网站，上面有数百部电影和剧集。出于某种原因，我决定点击《老爸老妈浪漫史》，当时并不知道我会多么深爱这部剧，也不知道它会如何改变我。我是那种对未来充满焦虑的人。我觉得自己错过了所有的青春体验，到现在还没亲吻过任何人，或者觉得不会有人爱上我。
Every day I think about where I will be in 10 years, what job will I be doing, who I will still be with, and who I am going to lose, and if anyone is ever going to love me the way Ted loves. Saying that makes me feel guilty of thinking so much about myself, knowing what is happening to the world, in politics, climate change, AI, social media. The list goes on. I often feel like the whole world is just going under, and that's just what my
我每天都在想10年后我会身处何方、我会做什工作、我还会和谁在一起、我会失去谁，以及是否会有人像泰德那样爱我。说出这些让我感到内疚，觉得自己想得太多，而此时世界正在发生那么多事——政治、气候变化、人工智能、社交媒体。名单还在继续。我常常觉得整个世界都在崩溃，而我的未来也将如此。
future will be like. All of these thoughts have taken up a lot of space the last four years, but since I met Ted Marshall, Lily, Robin, and Barney, the hope of everything eventually working out has been fighting the darker thoughts. How I met your mother comforts me in a way nothing else does. It taught me how important friendships are, but I have to let things change, and that every phase of your life, it's important, and will lead you to something. So thank you, Josh and Craig. Thank you so much for creating something that brings me hope that makes me laugh and cry, and that will always have a special place in my heart. That's beautiful. My God, Sophie, you were the wisest 15-year-old. I think I've ever met. We're really honored. The show has
所有这些想法在过去四年里占据了大量的空间，但自从我遇到了泰德、马歇尔、莉莉、罗宾和巴尼之后，一切最终都会好起来的希望一直在与那些黑暗的想法抗争。\n《老爸老妈浪漫史》以其他任何东西都无法比拟的方式抚慰了我。它教会了我友谊有多么重要，但我必须学会让事情顺其自然地改变，并且人生的每一个阶段都很重要，都会引领你走向某些事物。所以谢谢你们，乔什和克雷格。非常感谢你们创造了这样一部作品，它带给我希望，让我时而大笑时而落泪，并且它将永远在我心中占据一个特殊的位置。\n这太美妙了。天哪，苏菲，你是我见过的最聪明的15岁女孩。我们真的很荣幸，这部剧对你来说
meant that to you. And yeah, thank you for sharing that with us. Yeah, Sophie, I just want to say, I mean, you sound like you have an enormous heart. And I often find that about people that love how I met your mother. They're just very deeply feeling people. And I think that as you demonstrate in your letter, you can hold many things in your awareness at any given time. You can hold the pain and uncertainty of the world, the collective, the, you know, what's going on in the larger kind of landscape, as well as your own thoughts and feeling.
有着这样的意义。是的，谢谢你与我们分享这些。是的，苏菲，我只想说，听起来你有着一颗极其宽广的心。我经常在那些热爱《老爸老妈浪漫史》的人身上发现这一点。他们都是情感非常细腻的人。而且我认为，正如你在信中所展示的那样，你在任何特定的时刻都能在意识中容纳许多事物。你能够同时承载世界的痛苦与不确定性，那种集体层面的、你知道的，在更广阔背景下发生的事情，以及你自己的思想、情感、
and hurts and yearnings, and we can hold all of that. I'm reminded of something that I think it's in one of Elizabeth Gilbert's books or talks. She talks about in a refugee camp in some war-torn country, and it was just a terrible situation, and this person had gotten to know some of the young kids in this refugee camp, and they were all talking about who has a crush on who. And they were still, you know, even in this dire humanitarian situation, They were still wanted love and they still wanted to know who liked them and did they like, you know, who they liked. And that was still of interest to meet them. So I don't think that worrying about the world and being concerned about your own future and will you find someone to love and someone to love you. And I don't think those are mutually exclusive. I think that humans, we can hold all of that. And even though how I met your mother was not a directly political show, I think there is something political. about being a good friend
痛苦和渴望，我们能够包容所有这些。这让我想起了一件事，我想它在伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特（Elizabeth Gilbert）的一本书或演讲里提到过。她谈到一个战火纷飞国家的一个难民营，那里的情况简直糟透了，这个人开始认识难民营里的一些年轻孩子，他们都在谈论谁对谁有好感。他们依然，你知道的，即使在这种绝望的人道主义困境中，他们依然渴望爱情，依然想知道谁喜欢他们，他们又喜欢谁，你知道的，他们喜欢谁。对他们来说，这仍然是有趣的事。所以我不认为为世界担忧、关心自己的未来、担心自己是否会找到爱的人以及是否有人会爱你，这些是互不相容的。我认为人类，我们能够容纳所有这些。尽管《老爸老妈浪漫史》不是一部直接讲政治的剧，但我认为，做一个好朋友、
and showing up for people and being loyal and those things are needed in our society. Ted says love is the best thing we do. It's a somewhat a political statement on some level if you want to get granular about it. So I think we can do all those things. I don't think you have to feel bad about any of that. I am guilty.
为他人出现、保持忠诚，这里面蕴含着某种政治意义，而我们的社会正需要这些东西。泰德说“爱是我们做过的最好的事”。从某种层面上讲，如果你想抠得细一点，这也是一个带有政治意味的声明。所以我觉得我们可以把这些都做好。你真的不需要为这些感到内疚。我也有罪。
Please acquit me. All sins are forgiven. in New York City How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network
请宣判我无罪。所有罪孽皆被宽恕。在纽约市，《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔什·雷德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies Network 和 iHeartPodcasts 呈现并发行。
and Odyssey. This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Leav, and our co-producer is Doug Matica. Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Pointe to Blue Studios.
本集的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）。本剧由我——亚历克·利夫（Alec Leav）制作并剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡（Doug Matica）。我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Pointe to Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves）。
Digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg. Artwork by John Morrow. Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice. It really does help the show. Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski. Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
数字内容制作人、也就是“Z世代大师”是艾米莉·布隆伯格（Emily Blumberg）。封面插图由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）绘制。请在苹果播客或你喜爱的播客播放器上订阅、评分并评论本节目。这真的对节目很有帮助。我们的主题曲《纽约市》由我们自己的乔什·雷德纳创作，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供。特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit How We Made Your Mother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message. Your stories and questions are an important part of the show. Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at Josh Radner.com. Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at cragthomaswriter.com.
访问 HowWeMadeYourMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。你的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。请在 Substack 上订阅乔什·雷德纳的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐以及其他所有内容。在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说《That's Not How It Happened》，并在 craigthomaswriter.com 上查看他发表的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Father's Society, also on Substack. To learn more about how you make a difference, this show's ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website. People will, in fact, dance. The real question, it just hit me. Am I in love with you or just New York City? Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你还可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死者父亲协会”（Dead Father's Society）。要了解有关如何为本节目旨在为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹集资金的长期活动贡献力量的更多信息，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。人们其实是会跳舞的。真正的问题，我刚刚突然意识到：我是爱上了你，还是仅仅爱上了纽约市？谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。